hallo kekweit ich musste was zu trinken holen
auf geht's ja so ja war ich aber heute ging es nicht so gut ist nicht so geflutscht wie
es hätte flutschen sollen kekweit hd da alles klar ich muss jetzt erst mal kurz mein handy
suchen gucken was es sagt auf oder blau ist na ja und die color correction ist auch noch drin
aber die betreut die betreut habe ich zum glück runter gestellt okay das soll mal kurz handy
suchen ja doch schon gemacht also einfach echt anstrengend mit rennen
mal kurz kurz in meine stats mal schauen charts okay also meine garmin app ist der meinung plus
drei zwischen plus drei und plus vier performance condition ich bin mir da nicht so sicher das hat
sich nicht so angefühlt hat sich echt nicht so angefühlt aber gut wenn die app das meint
die wird es wahrscheinlich tatsächlich dadurch dass die
gespräche
geschwindigkeit herzfrequenz und so was alles hat vielleicht besser ist vielleicht
das richtige mindset ja das wird das ist es auch ich hatte tatsächlich nicht sonderlich viel bock
will der igel auch schon am start moin gar nicht gesehen jetzt das hochgescrollt
für den sub ist ja richtig exzellent monat monat rum prime sub abgelaufen muss dir das
recht an besos die kohle überwiesen werden irgendwie dadurch dass ich dass ich immer stream
musik anmache ist die video empfehlung etwas panать mittlerweile Euro 133 Pentium ja genau
das brauche ich heute unbedingt ein paar ordentliche ordentliche witz vorgeschlagen kriegen
das von mauri habe ich oft stream schon geguckt es hab ich die nächste mal doch schon mal als ich Huhl den T抡 lam i ug spheres im faz stitches und mir später researching politicsみたい zu folgen.
man denn hier fireship top 10 trends 2024 okay na dann fireship weiß es es geht eigentlich mit
der temperatur heute ist 8 grad das war überhaupt kein problem heute nicht so wie letztes letzten
sonntag könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch daran erinnern wo mir halb der bauch abgefroren ist
da wäre fast nichts mal hier gewesen letzten sonntag was minus 4 grad und ich bin über eine
stunde draußen rum gerannt und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt so zweieinhalb kilometer bevor ich
daheim war habe ich gemerkt ich merke irgendwie so meint mein bauch nicht mehr da habe ich da
dran gegriffen habe festgestellt oder ist ja richtig kalt und dann bin ich halt die letzten
zweieinhalb kilometer richtig schnell gerannt das
ist wieder alles warm wird und nicht noch weiter irgendwie abfriert und dann hat es
daheim bestimmt 15 bis 20 minuten gebraucht bis ich wieder alles gemerkt habe das ist keine so
gute idee ich glaube das ich glaube das nächste mal ziehe ich tatsächlich noch ich habe ja ich
habe ja immer ganz normale so ein funktionshemd an so was das wo man halt dann durch durchschwitzt
und also nicht also das wurde das wurde der schweiß raus raus geht dann habe ich noch so
eine gelbe signalweste drüber
und das war's das reicht normalerweise auch ohne problem weil man strengt sich an aber über eine
stunde wird es wohl echt zu kalt und ja keine ahnung was wir den teilweise abgeht naja zumindest
werde ich nächste mal wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder so kalt was ja 8 grad gar kein problem
wahrscheinlich irgendwie so eine jacke noch drüber ziehen dass das am besten halt eine
ärmellose jacke weil sonst wird es zu warm oder ist einfach der bauch nicht abfriert oh mein mein
mein vorstandsberuf ist jetzt nicht mehr so kalt und ich muss mich jetzt noch ein bisschen auf die
schau rechner ist der meinung ich muss eine zeit zum rebooten selekten
device is missing important quality fixes ach windows gehen wir nicht auf und sag ich starte
jetzt nicht neu das hot reload nicht schon die ganze zeit unter linux ach moment du was ich meine
ist refresh wenn sich die dateien geändert haben das meinst du nicht du meinst blazer zeug oder so
vermutlich du warst du warst wo unterwegs bei minus bei minus 12 minus 12 ist ordentlich ich glaube
so viel schaffen wir hier gar nicht ich glaube das kälteste die letzten jahre über war tatsächlich so
minus 45 das war aber auch echt das höchste der gefühl also das niedrigste der gefühle
schweden ja okay da ist jetzt gar nicht da ist wahrscheinlich minus 12 im winter noch easy
da geht wahrscheinlich noch viel viel weiter runter echt also was schon gemerkt habe ist bei
uns hier also in frankfurt frankfurt umland so wo ich wohne da ist eigentlich immer relativ mild
auch im winter wie gesagt morgens mal wirklich bisschen minus aber tagsüber eigentlich nie aber
wenn ich ein bisschen wenn ich ein bisschen irgendwie so richtung richtung spessart gebirge
und so far da kann man so richtig zu gucken nach ein paar kilometern
wenn ich da so in die richtung gefahren bin irgendwann fängt es dann so an wenn du so
guckst du so links und rechts sind auch viele felder fängt schon an so langsam weiß zu werden
und so nach carlos ist das so so 20 25 kilometer wenn ich dann da geht es geht auch per mal ein
bisschen den berg hoch da ist dann auf einmal der größte teil größte teil drumherum weiß also
ich kann wirklich so quasi in winter fahren innerhalb von so 20 30 kilometer um um landen
wo man sich für die海 cymbals und ich muss schon mal ganz lange die straße kehren dass ich
wenn ich hier ein paar tagen ist mir das das ist jetzt eigentlich ganz praktisch ist weil da muss
ich wenigstens nicht die straße kehren ich muss erst einmal die straße kehren ja ich muss erst
einmal die straße kehren dieses jahr das war vor keine ahnung ein paar tagen als es also als es
halt auch diese minus vier grad war sonst
okay heftiger schweden da schweden ist glaube ich auch ganz nice ich wollte noch mal irgendwann nach island im urlaub nachdem ich nicht der große urlaubfahrer bin aber ich werde jetzt schon jahre vor 60
vorgenommen bin die hingefahren mal gucken irgendwann wenn ich bock hab
gut dann lass uns mal kurz checken so die wichtigsten sachen heute was
trendet denn auf shithub aha china chinesen zeug trendet alles klar
wechat message okay was bin ich hier sehend ein china projekt hatte gab es
hier nicht so eine komische übersetzen button wo ist denn der chat ich bin
verwirrt was ist der übersetzen button github installieren zoom teilen gab es
hier nicht jemanden übersetzen button irgendwo bin ich jetzt bin ich jetzt
verwirrt es gab doch immer also moment ich bin auch im falschen browser kann
das sein bin ich jetzt aber gab es sich hier immer so ein translate button oben
normalerweise ich sehe auf die seite meiste übersetzt tatsächlich
normalerweise aber es gab doch immer oben rechts diesen translate bahn
ach jetzt
ach das hier im moment der wahl war der eben schon da keck wait
leute war noch eben noch nicht da der ist doch gerade aufgeploppt oder moment
er ist auch hier nicht da was haben sie was haben sie da wieder was haben sie
da was will ich sehen okay china chinesen my data is my decision
okay das ist in china glaube ich eine nicht so verbreitete ansicht
also
okay das ist irgendein wie chat chat
ak man zeug keine ahnung was auf einen schlag hier auf einmal übelst abgegangen
ist
alter guck mal hier ende des jahres kann es sein dass wie chat irgendwie irgendwie
das die irgendwie das interface geändert hat und dass die ganzen user abgefuckt
hat und das irgendwie so einen so einen weg ist weil er auch irgendwas restore
interface und so stand
Okay, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist, aber Extract WeChat Records, Export them into HTML, Word und CSV Documents.
Aha, ach das ist so ein Archiv, ein Archivsystem für WeChat.
Was WeChat ist, das ist das China, das China WhatsApp quasi.
Wobei, das viel zu kurz greift, du kannst über WeChat gefühlt alles machen.
Irgendwie von bezahlen bis Kredite abschließen oder sowas.
Mit WeChat kannst du einfach alles machen.
Das ist nicht nur WhatsApp, das ist alles in einem WeChat.
WeChat ist so die China-Chinesen-App, die jeder dort braucht.
Also, ups, Software Engineers, ne, ja, Most Important Skill.
Kann euch sagen, was der Most Important Skill ist?
Suchmaschine benutzen.
So, das ist der Most Important Skill.
Okay, also, China-Chinesen-WeChat-Zeug.
AI, keine Ahnung, aber...
Dinger, wo ich von der...
Das ist jetzt immer so ein Ding, wenn ich von der Beschreibung schon nicht weiß, was es sein soll, dann habe ich meistens auch keinen Bock, mir das anzugucken.
A Code-First-Agent-Framework for Seamlessly Planning and Executing Data Analytics Tasks.
Okay.
Irgendwelches Big-Data, High-IQ-Science-Zeug, nix für mich.
Das hatten wir schon.
AI, AI, AI, PDF-Generator, Social Media, Stalker-Zeug, AI, das kennen wir auch schon, AI, Tunnel, Power Toys, okay.
Alles klar, klingt nach Java.
Ja.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Wow.
Alter, das ist mal eine ausführliche Beschreibung, hä?
So eine ausführliche Beschreibung habe ich, also, das habe ich sehr selten gesehen, ob Gitter war.
Aber Spring Core, wenn ich das sehe, ist Java.
Das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Datenbank.
Noch mehr China-Zeug, Android.
Ach, ist das jetzt Open Source?
Haben sie es jetzt geschafft?
Nee, immer noch nicht.
Immer noch ein Grund für mich, es nicht zu benutzen.
Das ist ein...
Ein Python-Super-Set, was man es, ja, ahead of time kompilieren kann.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee, aber solange das nicht Open Source ist, benutze ich es nicht.
One API, okay.
China-Chinesen, äh, China-Chinesen-Language, ähm, Model, Machine Learning-Zeug, brauchen wir nicht.
Full-Stack-Framework for Laravel.
Moment, Laravel ist noch nicht genug, das braucht man...
Ach so, ja gut.
Und N-Sachen-Zeug, ja.
PHP-Zeug, okay.
Tabby.
Terraform, oh, Terraform-Trend, was haben die denn gemacht?
Was macht eigentlich der Terraform-Fork?
Wie heißt das nochmal?
Open...
Wie hieß das?
Open Tofu hieß das, glaube ich, der Terraform-Fork, ne?
Okay, der scheint tatsächlich ganz gut zu gehen.
Ist zumindest noch nicht dead.
Weiß man ja bei solchen Forks nie, ähm.
Homepro ist Mac, ja, ja, ist es.
Dieser, dieser Third-Party-Package-Manager für Mac.
Alpine-JavaScript-Zeug und Pocketbase.
Alles klar.
Ich stelle mit Begeisterung fest, dass zwar immer noch die Hälfte der Projekte oder ein Drittel der Projekte, die man hier sieht im Trend, AI ist, aber es nimmt ab.
Kommt glücklicherweise auch mal das ein oder andere.
Ich bin wieder durch hier.
In der .NET-Welt irgendwas Spannendes trendet.
Leute, ratet mal, was es bei mir heute zu essen gibt.
Ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Der Chat lag Critical Information.
Echt, geht das mittlerweile?
Aber warum, ich frage mich gerade, warum ich das unter Linux verwenden sollte.
Ich hätte jetzt vermutet, dass die meisten Packages da drauf halt ziemlich macOS-spezifisch sind.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Woher weißt du das?
Oh, Leute, ich habe hier nur...
Heute gibt es sogar richtig viel Nudeln mit Lachs, weil ich hatte gestern nicht so viel Hunger und habe die Hälfte übrig gelassen.
Das gibt es heute noch dazu, zu der normalen Portiongröße für Sonntag.
Also heute gibt es nicht nur Nudeln mit Lachs, heute gibt es massive viel Nudeln mit Lachs.
Das ist vielleicht was für dich.
Okay.
Kaufst du immer Tiefkühl...
Ne, das ist kein Tiefkühllachs.
Das ist Lachs...
Also ja doch, Tiefkühl.
Also nicht...
Also, das ist so ein geschweißter Lachs vom Lidl.
Die haben da so einen Schrank mit so Glastüren.
Da ist gekühlt.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht gefroren.
Das ist nicht gefroren.
Was ist denn die richtige...
Korrekt.
Exzellent.
Was ist denn die richtige Lachs-zu-Nudel-Ratio?
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also, ich mache das meistens so.
Dass ich...
Ich würde mal sagen, so 1 zu 4.
1...
Also quasi...
3 Viertel vom Teller Nudel.
1 Viertel Lachs.
Welchen Lachs verwendest du konkret?
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Das ist so eingeschweißt.
Da geht es da an den Schrank.
Du holst so ein eingeschweißtes Stück Lachs raus.
Das ist ein langer Lachs.
Ist das.
So am Stück.
Und Rezept gibt es nicht.
Ich kann euch sagen, das ist super simpel.
Kochst Nudel im Wasser.
Machst den Lachs in der Pfanne.
Und wenn man es dann besonders übertreiben will,
kann man auch so eine Mischung aus Senf machen.
Für die Soße.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, normalerweise mache ich einfach nur Lachs-Nudel
und schmeiße dann süß-sauer-China-Chinesen-Soße drüber.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
meistens kocht sogar meine Mutter und gar nicht ich.
Also insofern...
Easy.
Gar nichts machen.
Aber wenn ich das mache,
dann verzichte ich auf die Senf-Soße,
weil ich zu faul bin, das zu machen.
Dann koche ich einfach Nudel,
schmeiße den Lachs in die Pfanne
und dann mache ich China-Süß-Sauer-Soße drüber.
Ja.
Das ist hier Flying Goose.
Nicht das hier.
Flying Goose.
Soße.
Das kommt da drüber.
Moment.
Wo ist es?
Die da.
Aber...
Das ist alles die falsche.
Das ist alles nicht die richtige.
Die haben so süß-sauer-Soße noch.
Ja, sowas.
Sowas.
Genau sowas in der Richtung.
Mache ich da meistens drüber.
So, fertig.
Ist das die?
Die norwegische Seelachs-Seite.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Warte mal.
Ist das...
Ey, das könnte das echt sein.
Ja.
Also Haut hat sie auf jeden Fall auf einer Seite.
Das könnte durchaus das hier sein.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da sieht das Sache sehr ähnlich.
Ja.
Gut, dass wir jetzt die wichtigen Sachen geklärt haben.
Chat sehr interessiert.
Ja, wundert mich auch auf einmal, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum ist der Chat so interessiert?
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Programmier Sprachengeld und Homeoffice-Statistik in Deutschland.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Wie gesagt, Rezept gibt es ja nicht wirklich.
Das ist super simpel.
Kochst Nudel.
Machst ein bisschen Salz ins Wasser.
Am besten ist natürlich, du lässt das Wasser erstmal kochen und machst den Salz dann rein,
weil das Wasser hat schneller gekocht.
Auf der anderen Seite ist ja egal.
Letztendlich musst du es...
Ja.
Zumindest machst du Salz, Nudel.
Und dann schmeißt du, machst ein bisschen Öl rein und dann schmeißt du den Lachs da rein und fertig.
Also, das ist, das ist, das kriegt, das kriegt wirklich jeder hin.
Chat, wenn ich das hinkriege, kriegt ihr das auch hin.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Transparent IT-Job-Market-Report DACH-Region.
Das ist geil.
German-Tech-Jobs.de, aber das Ding ist in Englisch, oder?
Nice.
Na gut, vielleicht ist es ja International Information Zeug.
Also.
What information?
Okay, da.
About German...
Ach so, das ist die Webseite.
Die haben auch eine App.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was sind das für eine Webseite?
Kennt man die?
Moment, das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Ist das, ist das die Seite von, von, von den YouTube-Leuten?
Nee.
Irgendwelche Schweizer.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nicht von YouTube-Leuten.
Gucken.
Mal gucken.
Was gibt's denn?
Was gibt's denn in Frankfurt?
Was gibt's denn da so?
Ich, ich brauch keine E-Mail.
Sag mal.
IT-Chapter-Lead-Test-Automation.
Alter, das klingt ja mal richtig six-head, Alter.
IT-Chapter-Lead.
Nee.
IT-Chapter-Lead-Test-Automation.
FMX.
Guck mal mal, wie es im Osten aussieht, ja.
Äh, Moment.
Wollen wir mal Frankfurt...
Wollen wir mal Frankfurt weg?
Na ja.
Ey, sag das mal gar nicht.
Bäm, in Berlin geht's halt richtig zur Sache.
Aber gut, Berlin ist ja auch nur...
Nee, ist ja auch nur teilweise Osten, ja.
In Dresden gibt's...
Ja doch, in Osten ist schon deutlich weniger.
Na, hier ist schon, hier ist schon...
Ja, ja, das stimmt schon.
Warum ist hier ein Handy?
iOS-Entwicklung.
Moment.
Heißt das, es gibt genau einen Job hier oben in Rostock?
Ja, ja, ja.
Oder bezahlen die was dafür, dass sie gehighlighted werden?
Okay.
Aber im Osten ist es tatsächlich wenig.
Also in Frankfurt, wie zu erwarten, halt richtig, richtig viel wieder.
Aber Frankfurt ist halt auch, wo du hinspuckst, ein Rechenzentrum oder irgendein Softwareentwickler
oder irgendeine Bank oder irgendeine Versicherung oder irgendwelche Systemläden und sonst was.
In Frankfurt geht's halt...
Frankfurt und München, da gibt's, da gibt's richtig was.
Okay, lass mal kurz checken.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Frankfurt...
C++.
Oh, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Dazu, dazu fällt mir nur ein...
Ja, fällt mir gar nicht ein, weil ich das im Out nicht finde.
Das hier.
No, God!
Blockchain.
Jawohl, kann ich mich jetzt bewerben?
Jetzt, wo ich offiziell Blockchain-Experte bin, kann ich, kann ich da...
Da werde ich gesucht hier.
Blockchain.
C++.
Java.
C++-Engineer-Blockchain.
Senior Full-Stack-Engineer.
Taunusanlage.
Auch geil.
Von 1000 bis 1 Million Euro.
Nice.
Okay, aber was ich bei denen schon mal ganz gut finde, die geben eine Gehaltsspanne an.
Wobei halt 30.000 Gehalt ist schon recht viel.
Für 65k hätte ich keinen Bock.
Für 95k auch nicht.
Also alles, was weniger ist als beim aktuellen, ne, dann nicht.
Aber ich meine, da geht's...
Da geht's schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Was wollen die hier denn?
Lass mal, lass mal, just for fun draufgucken.
Okay.
Ein Senior Full-Stack-Engineer wollen die haben.
Five-Head.
Richtig, Six-Head-Time wollen die haben.
Also, was wollen die?
Big Data, Blockchain, DevOps, Docker, Git, IoT.
IoT auch noch.
Java, JavaScript, Machine Learning, Python, SQL, Node.
Okay, da ist, da ist schlicht und klar, kann einfach mal alles, Full-Stack hat einfach mal alles dabei.
Okay.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung, Teilbereich IoT.
Blockchain, DLD, nein, nein, nein, DLT oder Big Data.
Fundierte Programmierkenntnisse, Craft-Datenbanken, Erfahrungen in der Modernheit.
Der von Continuous Integration Testing, Git, Docker, Infrastructure as Code.
Bereitschaft zu gelegentlichen Dienstreisen.
No!
Ja, ganz ehrlich, diese...
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall nicht übel, dass zumindest mal eine Range dran steht.
Kann man, kann man es sortieren?
Sortieren nach Geld?
Geht das vielleicht?
Sortieren nach Geld geht nicht, gell?
Das ist ja doof.
Kann man nicht, kann man nicht?
Ich würde, ich würde gerne nach Gehalt sortieren.
Geht nicht, ne?
Senior Cloud Architect, das war's für mich.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, ich suche nichts Neues.
Ich war noch nie auf der Seite.
Ich dachte mir, wir scrollen, wir scrollen mal kurz.
Ein Frontend Engineer Manager.
Das ist auch eine geile Kombination.
Das heißt, du machst es nicht selbst, du managst nur noch die Frontend Engineers.
Senior Fullstack Web Mobile.
Ah, da gibt es übrigens ordentlich Kohle.
Was wollen die hier denn?
Zeig mal her.
Senior Cloud Architect.
Weiterentwicklung von DevOps-Prozent-Tools zur Unterstützung von Continuous Delivery-Projekten.
Strategiefolge, okay, bla bla bla.
Cloud Microservice.
Container-Technologien, Cloud-Infrastructure, Microservices, Docker und Kubernetes oder Kubernetes oder Kubernetes oder wie auch immer.
AWS, Azure, Google.
Ja, habe ich.
Wie gesagt, ich suche ja nichts, aber man kann ja mal gucken.
Gute Kenntnisse in Programmier- und Skriptsprachen, wie zum Beispiel Oracle DB.
Öh, öh.
Was kommt als nächstes noch?
SAP und Sybase und alles.
Perl.
Wenn du noch jemanden findest, der das zu würdigen weiß.
Perl selbst ist ja schon ziemlich oldschool.
Umfassende Kenntnisse in den Container, zum Beispiel Docker und Virtualisierung.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, das würde gut auf mich passen.
Ich suche nichts, außerdem ist es nur Vollzeit, auch nichts.
Aber das würde zumindest von der Beschreibung her ganz gut passen.
Verantwortlichkeit.
Ach, die verschachern irgendwie Personal und so.
Ne, ne, da hätte ich schon wieder keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, na gut.
Wie dem auch sei, eigentlich wollten wir uns diesen Report angucken.
Also Perl, Perl ist glaube ich eines der Programmiersprachen, die, wie soll man sagen, so den, den, mit den steilsten Abstieg hingelegt haben, so die letzten, die letzten 15 Jahre.
Teilweise mal super beliebt, jeder zweite hat was in Perl gemacht und heute ist Perl komplett so Sonderlocke, so komplett raus eigentlich.
Der andere Seite, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, man hat es ja mit anderen Programmiersprachen auch gesehen, Ruby auch.
Ruby ist auch so ein Ding.
Ruby war 2007 rum, so voll mega gehypt.
Da waren die ganzen Ruby on Rails Rockstar Developer, aber sie hat nichts mit GTA zu tun, ne.
Rockstar Developer am Start.
Und heute ist Ruby auch nicht mehr angesagt.
Aber ich würde sagen, immer noch angesagter als Perl.
Ja, ich mag Ruby.
Ruby ist, neben C Sharp, meine Lieblingsprogrammiererin.
Das ist die Programmiersprache, wobei ich eigentlich sagen muss, mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil du kannst mittlerweile mit Ruby nichts mehr anfangen.
Weil es stimmt ja auch nicht, du kannst theoretisch schon, aber so wirklich, es macht ja auch keinen Sinn, so komplett unbeliebte Sachen.
Also, heute, heute ist es eigentlich hauptsächlich bei mir C Sharp und JavaScript und ein bisschen Go.
Aber Rails, Rails ist nice.
Also ich, ich mochte, ich mochte Ruby on Rails richtig.
Mittlerweile hätte ich tatsächlich gar keinen großartigen Bock mehr, irgendwas mit Ruby on Rails zu machen, weil ich mich so sehr an ASP.NET Core gewöhnt habe.
Naja, lieben würde ich nicht sagen.
Rust ist schon teilweise ganz schön der Abfuck.
Das Einzige, was ich halt überhaupt nicht abkann, ist C++.
Auch wenn ich es manchmal benutzen muss für irgendwelche Microcontroller.
Also lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz in diesen Trend gucken.
How many years have you already been working in the tech industry?
Da haben wir auch schon mal eine Umfrage gemacht, oder?
Chat, wollen wir auch mal eine Umfrage machen?
Das machen wir auch mal.
Wir gucken mal, wie repräsentativ der Chat ist hier.
Vote, äh Moment.
Ne, Poll war das, muss ich mal.
Sick, sick, haben wir tatsächlich einmal einen Stream gemacht.
Okay, wie lange, wie lange arbeitet ihr schon in der IT?
Oder schreibt, schreibt, komm, wir formulieren das so.
Wie lange arbeitet ihr hier in der Tech-Industry?
Wie lange arbeitet ihr schon in der Tech-Industry?
Machen wir auch mal hier 0 bis 2 und machen wir die gleichen.
3 bis 5.
5 bis 5, das ist ja eine krasse Spanne.
Das war doch klar, dass die meisten 5 bis 15 Jahre, oder?
15 plus.
Okay, Duration.
Wir erlauben keine additional votes.
Jetzt zeigt mal, gucken wir mal.
Also ich bin mittlerweile 15 Jahre plus.
Definition Tech-Industrie, gibt's nicht.
43 Jahre, ja eindeutig 15 plus.
Da bist du aber echt die Ausnahme.
Da bist du, bist du in Schweden in Rente oder so?
Ja, das war eigentlich klar, dass 5 bis 15 gewinnt, oder?
Das ist eine riesen Spanne.
Okay, es ist im Prinzip, ist im Prinzip ähnlich, ne?
Hier, guck mal, 18, 18, 15, 20.
Es geht, aber es geht in die ähnliche Richtung.
IoT.
Hardware-Hardware-Entwicklung, nice.
Also 5 bis 5, es war, es war ja irgendwie klar, aber sag mal so, es geht in die ähnliche Richtung, ja?
Hier 18, 18, 16, hier ein bisschen wie, also es ist, es ist, es ist tatsächlich ziemlich ähnlich, was hier rausgekommen ist, zu, was hier rausgekommen ist.
Golang gehört zu den Top-Technologien in der Schweiz, nice.
108.000 Schweizer Franken.
Moment, was ist denn das in Euro?
Ja, dafür, dafür kann man, dafür kann man aufstehen.
Wobei, wenn ich nach Reddit, wenn ich nach Reddit gehen würde, wenn ich nach Reddit gehen würde, kann man dafür eigentlich nicht aufstehen.
Also, also Reddit, Subreddit Arbeitsleben oder sowas würde ich jetzt schreiben, dafür stehe ich morgens nicht auf und wenn ich auf der Arbeit bin, gleich Kündigung raus und dem Chef auf den Tisch kacken und sowas.
Aber Subreddit Arbeitsleben ist eh, die sind eh teilweise echt bepeger da.
Letztens auch wieder irgendwas gelesen, einer hat einen Post, also einer hat einen Reddit, Reddit Threat erstellt, so Probleme mit, Problem mit Kollege und hat dann übelst drüber abgerantet, wie scheiße der ist und, und er das immer alles checkt.
Und ich hab mir halt beim Lesen schon so gedacht, ey, also ich hätt mit dir auch meine Probleme, also wenn er in echt so ist, wie in diesem Reddit Post, ja.
Aber die Leute haben ihn dann so voll ermutigt noch.
So nach dem Motto, ja, gleich, gleich melden bei der, beim Chef ansprechen das nächste Mal, wenn nicht schon mal direkt neuen Job suchen.
Was zum Teufel ist bei euch los, man?
Die schlagen da immer voll übers Ziel raus.
Man könnte, man könnte ja auch einfach mal probieren, sich ein bisschen normal zu verhalten, sodass man mit den anderen Leuten klarkommt.
Ich mein, ich bin jetzt sicherlich nicht der Sozialste.
Bei uns gibt's hier im Radio.
Mittags, wenn ich unten in der Küche sitze und manchmal Mittag esse, da, da, ups, da hab ich manchmal Radio an und da gibt es so eine komische Werbung, die mich, die mich extrem verwirrt.
Da, da gibt's dann, da gibt's dann, ich, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie die geht.
Zumindest kommt in der Werbung vor, wollen Sie mit Menschen in all ihren Facetten arbeiten?
Oder, nee, nee, nee, nicht wollen Sie, arbeiten Sie jetzt mit Menschen in all ihren Facetten?
Und da denke ich mir so, Alter, ich will schon nicht.
Ich will nicht mit Menschen ohne jeglich, also, mit, mit, nicht mal ohne Facetten will ich mit denen arbeiten, ne?
Dann kommt er, kommen Sie jetzt zu uns, zur Diakonie, irgendwas.
Dann denke ich, oh nein, Alter, geh mal bloß weg.
Also, ich bin, ich bin ja schon auch nicht der Allersozialste, was das angeht und ich will eigentlich meine Ruhe.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, manchmal, manchmal, wir haben auch eins, zwei Leute bei uns, die, die richtig nervig sein können.
Aber manchmal ist gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man selbst einfach zumindest mal versucht.
Irgendwie halbwegs normal mit den Leuten umzugehen, dann, dann beruhigen sich viele auch wieder, ja?
Also, weil wenn man sich vorstellt, wenn man sich vorstellt, die sind da alle so drauf, so wie ich,
dann, dann braucht man manchmal ein bisschen, bis man, bis man sich aneinander gewöhnt hat.
Also, ich, ich, ich weiß auch nicht, was da auf Reddit, was da auf Reddit los ist.
Ja, und zu dieser Frage, hat der Teambuilding-Workshop was gebracht?
Also, bringen tun solche Workshops ja eigentlich nie was.
Ich habe da auch kein Geheimnis drum gemacht, dass ich keinen Bock drauf hatte.
Es gab so eine Abschlussrunde, da wurde gefragt, und wie war es?
Habe ich halt gesagt, boah, ich hatte eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf und, also, aber es ging schon, so.
Und dann meinte der Trainer so, okay, mindest, mindest Messlatte erreicht, also, ja.
Ja, zumindest, es war von den ganzen Workshops, die ich bisher machen musste, der erträglich.
Sagen wir es mal so, ja.
Also, ich meine, besser als der Workshop, wo wir gegen die Wand gespuckt haben, der war schon ganz okay.
Natürlich gab es auch, gab es auch wieder jede Menge komische Spielchen, Teamspielchen, die wir machen mussten,
aber es war gar nicht so übel.
Ja, das falsche Grindset-Mindset.
Ach ja, und von meiner Liste konnte ich einen Punkt anbringen, der dann auch, sagen wir so, etwas oberflächlich behandelt wurde, aber immerhin, ja.
Hat er auch gemeint, hat er noch nie gesehen, dass einer mit einer Liste anrückt.
Das habe ich gleich schon gesagt, also, sollten wir nochmal das machen, dann nehme ich wieder eine mit, weil, dass da auch mal, dass da auch mal was ordentliches, was, was, was Wichtiges diskutiert wird, anstatt nur Spielchen zu machen.
Also, das habe ich etwas netter ausgedrückt, ja, das habe ich so nicht gesagt.
So, also, Umfrage, okay, deckt sich, deckt sich mit unserer Umfrage ungefähr.
So.
Ich kann euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, vorbereitet sein ist die halbe Miete.
Egal, bei größeren, egal, ob es bei größeren Meetings ist.
Zu Präsentationen, selbstverständlich, oder zu irgendwelchen Workshops.
Weil, wenn ihr nur ein Minimal vorbereitet seid, seid ihr schon um Längen mehr vorbereitet als alle anderen.
Und ihr könnt das Ganze viel entspannter angehen.
Also, es macht oftmals Sinn, vor irgendwelchen Terminen, sich einfach mal eine Viertelstunde hinzusetzen und sich zwei, drei Punkte zu überlegen.
Und dann ist easy.
So, ja.
Siehst du, da hatten wir fast mehr Votes auf Twitch.
Nein, nicht ganz, aber ich glaube, wir hatten, keine Ahnung, 80 Votes oder so.
So, weiter geht's.
Key Insights.
Das ist der Key zum Success, Leute.
Da müssen wir gleich mal die low-hanging fruits ernten, um Synergieeffekte klar zu machen.
So, also, die Key Insights.
Und was haben die euch da so beigebracht?
Ich hoffe, sie haben euch beigebracht, nicht am Ende zu sagen, vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Das ist diese Bullet Point.
Das ist absoluter Schmutz.
Kommt drauf an, was man damit macht.
Also, wenn man einfach nur jetzt pro Folie 15 Punkte hinklatscht, dann ist das wahrscheinlich nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Nun gut.
Also, was sind denn die Key Insights?
93% arbeiten remote, mindestens einen Tag die Woche.
Okay.
Immerhin.
52% der Leute, die das beantwortet haben, haben die Option.
Zur vollen Remote-Woche.
Das glaube ich aber nicht.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt eher, das ist so eine Geschichte von, hey, lieber Arbeitgeber, ihr sagt doch, ihr habt eine Homeoffice-Regelung.
Könnte ich auch fünf Tage voll remote arbeiten?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Kannst du, kannst du.
Und wenn du es dann machen willst, dann geht's nicht.
Also, wir hätten nicht die Chance zur work fully remote.
Nee, das machen wir jetzt keine Umfrage.
Oder soll ich da eine Umfrage zu machen?
Chat, ihr könnt ja mal schreiben im Chat.
Also, ich glaube, die wenigsten von euch hätten wirklich die Möglichkeit, also realistisch betrachtet.
Wenn ihr euch wirklich vorstellen würdet, ihr fragt jetzt, kann ich 100% arbeiten?
Bei den wenigsten würde das wirklich klappen.
Ja, außer bei Stellen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass deine Stellen auch 100% remote ausgeschrieben war, oder?
Eventuell bist du ja auch, sagen wir mal, geografisch gar nicht in der Nähe.
Echt?
Ihr könnt...
Na, okay.
Kommen wir, machen wir, machen wir noch einmal eine Umfrage.
Also, ich, ich muss einen Tag die Woche nach Frankfurt, der Rest ist remote.
Das ist für mich optimal.
Könntet ihr 100% remote arbeiten?
Nicht könntet, dürft ihr 100% remote arbeiten?
Ja, nein.
Machen wir nochmal eine Umfrage.
Also, ich dürfte nicht 100%, aber ich meine, einen Tag die Woche finde ich voll und das ist echt kein Problem.
Das ist eigentlich sogar ganz gut.
Das ist nämlich der Tag, wo...
Also, ich gehe da immer hin.
An dem Tag, wo eh nur mehr oder weniger gemietet wird, den ganzen Tag.
Ich mache halt den Tag dann nichts, außer zu mieten.
Und das kann man auch vor Ort machen.
Dann sieht man die Leute mal kurz.
Nicht, dass das unbedingt notwendig wäre.
Oh, tatsächlich?
So viel, ja?
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Dass...
Dass fast 40% das möglich ist.
Ja, 80% Büro ist ja doof.
Also, bei uns ist es nicht.
Es ist nicht direkt ein Team-Tag, aber ich mache das halt.
Also, wir haben halt alle 14 Tage so ein...
Wir sind super agil und mieten den ganzen Tag.
Also, ihr habt das richtig gehört.
Den ganzen Tag mieten ist agil.
Und da mache ich eh nichts.
Da bin ich vor Ort und dann, je nachdem wie es passt, die andere Woche.
Ich finde auch, dass es durchaus Sinn macht.
Okay, also weiter.
Flexibilität.
Was meint...
Das muss ich mal lesen.
Das checke ich gerade nicht, was?
Flexibility of place and no commute among the main reasons.
Ach so, okay.
Ah ja.
Okay, Flexibilität und dass die Leute nicht pendeln müssen, ist der hauptsächliche Grund,
warum die Leute remote arbeiten wollen.
Ja, das unterschreibe ich.
Das und...
What the f...
Das unterschreibe ich.
Wie ist das bei euch mit Team- und Abteilungsleiter?
Nein, die sind tatsächlich öfters in der Bank.
Die haben aber auch die ein oder anderen Homeoffice.
Warum die unbedingt offline mieten müssen, weiß ich nicht.
Aber wenn sie wollen, sollen sie machen.
Weiterer Grund, nie Führungskraft zu werden.
Lul.
Remote work leads...
Oh, habe ich spannend gesagt.
Ich bin auch...
Pepega-Brain...
Beim falschen Job gewesen, wenn ich spannend gesagt habe.
Lul weh.
So.
Leak-ge.
Remote work leads to a sense of disconnection from co-workers...
Äh, nein.
Finde ich gar nicht.
Finde ich überhaupt nicht.
Was ist mit den Leuten los, Mann?
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Generationending.
Ich glaube, gerade viele, potenziell...
Viele ab meiner Generation und drüber empfinden das.
Und viele ab meiner Generation und drunter empfinden das nicht.
Meine Generation ist so gespalten.
Es gibt ja in meiner Generation auch, sag mal, so schon super viele Boomer-Leute.
Und es gibt Leute, die mit fast 40 noch in Twitch-Emails reden.
Was sicherlich nicht die Regel ist.
Aber ich glaube, durch meine Generation geht es so durch.
Ähm, okay.
Die Mehrzahl der Leute fühlen sich nicht bedroht durch AI, dass das irgendwann mal ihre Jobs macht.
Da fühle ich mich auch null bedroht durch.
Wir haben gestern Chat-GPT versucht, mal eine Advent-of-Code-Aufgabe lösen zu lassen.
Was da rausgekommen ist, war kompletter Schrott.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn irgendwie ein Arbeitgeber was von Familie erzählt, ist das eh Scam.
Das ist Scam.
Dass du kostenlos mehr machst.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, sobald denen an dir irgendwas nicht passt, bist du auch schneller weg, als du gucken kannst.
So viel zum Thema Familie, ja.
Auf der anderen Seite ist eigentlich Familie immer noch der bessere Begriff.
Weil ihr wisst ja, was der Unterschied zwischen Freunde und Familie ist.
Freunde kannst du dir aussuchen, Familie nicht.
Also Familie trifft es dann vielleicht sogar noch besser in dem Fall.
Okay, 70% der Leute, die umgezogen sind für den Job, freuen sich darüber.
Sind happy danach.
Ich hätte keinen Bock, hier wegzuziehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, wenn es um neue Jobs geht, das Gehalt und die Option für Homeoffice sind die wichtigsten zwei Punkte.
Ja, klar.
Ist bei mir auch so.
Also, Gehalt und Homeoffice.
Es kommen natürlich noch ein paar Sachen dabei.
Bei mir kommt zum Beispiel bei, dass ich nur, dass Teilzeitarbeiten okay ist.
Aber trotzdem.
Wie ist das bei euch, Chat?
Gehalt.
Gehalt und Remote-Work-Möglichkeiten, oder?
Oder was ist euch, was ist, wäre euch was ähnlich wichtig wie Gehalt und Remote-Arbeit-Möglichkeiten?
Also bei mir trifft es das, trifft es das eigentlich ganz gut.
Tech-Stack.
Spannende Arbeit.
Wochen Arbeitszeit.
Obstkorb.
Ja, der ist natürlich ganz wichtig, der Obstkorb.
Tischkehle.
Ihr schreibt ein Flürze, Leute.
Lasst das mal, Chat, lasst das bitte keine Personalabteilung hier lesen.
Weil dann fühlen die sich wieder bestätigt, oder keine Personalabteilung, ist ja falsch, keine irgendwelche Recruiting-Leute lesen.
Dann fühlen die sich wieder bestätigt, dass Tischkehle und Obstkorb der beste, die beste Möglichkeit ist, IT-Leute anzusprechen.
Ist dir Remote-Work oder Teilzeit wichtiger, wenn du nur eins haben könntest?
Remote-Work.
Weil die Zeit, die du sparst, durch nicht hin und her fahren müssen und Flexibilität, die du hast, auch mal zum Tierarzt fahren zu können oder sowas, wenn es gerade wichtig ist und mitten am Tag.
Remote-Work ist wichtiger, als nur 80% zu arbeiten.
Aber glücklicherweise stellt sich die Frage halt gar nicht.
Außerdem, außerdem könnte ich dann einfach in der 5-Tage-Woche insgesamt mehr rumgammeln und dann wäre der eine Tag auch wieder frei.
Ja, so könnte man es auch sehen.
Aber, also mir wäre Remote-Work tatsächlich wichtiger, aber glücklicherweise stellt sich die Frage nicht.
Weil ich das beides halt schon, schon sage, so, bei Bewerbung.
Das wissen die.
Ja, das wissen die.
Das heißt, jemand, der mich einlädt, der weiß schon, so ungefähr, was Sache ist.
Hat bei mir auf der Arbeit auch keinen überrascht.
Weil das habe ich gleich von Anfang an transparent gesagt, dass ich nur 80% Teilzeit arbeiten will.
Und seriously, ganz ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung, 80% Leute arbeiten auch nicht bedeutend weniger als 100% Leute.
Weil ich meine, seriously, von dem einen Tag, wo du nicht da bist, ist...
Äh...
Ist eh wieder ein Großteil Gemiete und sonst was.
Und es ist, es macht, glaube ich, gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Kantine ist extrem nice, für den Fall, dass man öfters vor Ort ist.
Okay.
Ähm...
Das durchschnittliche Einkommen von Softwareentwicklern in Deutschland ist 62.100 Euro.
Okay.
Gut, das geht ja von, geht ja über alles.
Von, äh, quasi...
Gerade...
Frisch fertig zu...
Senior-Five-Head-Architekt, so.
Okay, im Durchschnitt ist in der Schweiz...
Die, äh, das verdienst 106.000 Schweizer Franken.
Ja.
Und billiger.
Hier, sich Leute.
Die, die Schweiz, die, die outsourced bestimmt nach Deutschland, weil es billiger ist.
Remote Work.
Natürlich, natürlich mit, mit, mit Macbook.
Auf dem Schoß am Strand.
So wie halt...
Remote Work nicht aussieht normalerweise.
Bestimmt auch noch AI-generiertes Bild oder so.
Okay, 93% auf...
Äh, der Leute, die geantwortet haben, können...
Das haben wir ja schon gesehen.
Haben wir schon gesehen.
Ja, bei mir ist es auch hier 37%.
Zwei bis vier Tage kann man remote, kann man remote arbeiten.
Das ist außerdem auch sehr unergonomisch.
Ich mein, immerhin hat er so einen Stuhl mit so einer Mini-Armlehne.
Ja.
Es ist nicht so einfach, nach Deutschland zu outsourcen.
Das hab ich mir fast schon gedacht.
Was ist Bürokratie...
Bürokratie ist hier schon einfach.
Kannst du den PDF-Link in Chat posten?
Da steht noch im...
Wobei...
Hier.
Also, weiter geht's.
Vorlieben.
Okay, was, was mögen die Leute am ehesten?
Hybrid, optional Home Office.
Äh, optional Office.
Hybrid required Office.
Fully Office, fully remote no Office.
Okay, das war ja klar.
Ne, das war ja klar.
Die meisten Leute bevorzugen full remote.
Die nächsten...
Äh, überwiegende Teile Leute bevorzugt Hybrid, optional Office.
Ich muss sagen, ich bevorzuge auch Hybrid.
Wenn das möglich...
Ich mein, ich würde auch fully remote machen, wenn die Firma das halt dementsprechend darauf ausgelegt ist.
Aber ich find Hybrid gar nicht so schlecht.
Allerdings, ähm, in der Variante hier.
Find ich nicht verkehrt, dass du ins Office gehen kannst, wenn's dir danach ist.
Manche Leute machen das einfach gern.
Ich finde, man sollte denen auch das nicht vorschreiben.
Ich finde, beide Möglichkeiten sind sinnvoll.
Und wenn...
Wenn die Firma äh, ne gewisse Anzahl an Mitarbeitern hat und Wechselarbeitsplätze, kann die sicherlich auch die ein oder andere an Bürofläche sparen.
Okay.
Was...
Das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Was enjoyen Home Office Enjoyer?
Was enjoyen die Leute am meisten am...
Am remote, remote worken?
Ja.
Die meisten enjoyen work from everywhere.
Das ist mir tatsächlich vollkommen wurscht, weil ich arbeite eh nicht from everywhere.
Ich arbeite hier, dort an der Stelle, wo ich auch gerade sitze.
Im Stream, nämlich in meinem Arbeitszimmer.
Nur, dass ich da nicht streame.
Ähm, ja.
Ich mein, die Option ist theoretisch ganz cool.
Aber für mich nicht wirklich relevant.
Das ist für mich der grü...
Der wirklich der, der...
Ein riesen Pluspunkt.
Ja. Kein...
Kackbahn hin und zurück gefahre.
Das ist für mich der größte, größte Pluspunkt.
Einfach Zeit ersparen.
Cost Savings...
Würde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so sehen.
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Wobei man sich fragen kann, ob da wirklich so viel gespart wird unterm Strich.
Bisschen vielleicht, ja.
Und das finde ich auch nicht...
Also ich würde tatsächlich...
Kein Pendeln und Productivity Boost sagen.
Ich merke das an den Tagen, wo ich tatsächlich mal nach Frankfurt in die Versicherung fahren muss.
Dann ist...
Ich mache an dem Tag nichts.
Und es liegt nicht daran, dass ich mich da hinsetze und sage, ich will nichts machen.
Aber es ist im Vergleich zu daheim einfach viel schwieriger, sich zu konzentrieren.
Und überhaupt schwieriger, irgendwie so klare Gedanken zu fassen.
Und nicht abgelenkt zu werden.
Es ist echt viel, viel einfacher, konzentriert, produktiv was daheim zu machen, wie vor Ort.
Also Cost Savings ist bei mir tatsächlich wenig.
Weil ich habe ein Deutschland-Ticket.
Das habe ich bei einem Tag die Woche.
Und das habe ich auch bei vier Tagen die Woche.
How much...
Okay.
How much time are you saving?
Wie viel Zeit sparen wir dadurch am Tag, dass wir nicht pendeln müssen?
Also ich spare 1-2 Stunden auf jeden Fall.
Ich brauche 45...
Wenn alles gut läuft.
Eigentlich ist es sogar theoretisch noch mehr.
Theoretisch ist es sogar noch mehr.
Also ich brauche 45 Minuten...
Warte mal, lass mal überlegen.
Ja, also sagen wir mal so.
Ich brauche ungefähr 45 Minuten.
Dass ich den...
Dass ich auf dem Rückweg dann vom Hauptbahnhof laufe, das ist ja mein Ding.
Das hat ja damit nichts zu tun.
Ich würde ja danach auch laufen.
Sagen wir mal so, ich spare im Durchschnitt vielleicht sagen wir mal so 2 Stunden am Tag.
Es können aber halt auch mal, wenn die Bahn wieder mal richtig reinschreist, was dann leider überwiegende Teil der Fälle der Fall ist, auch mal 2 Stunden plus sein.
Wir haben bei uns jemanden im Team, der kommt irgendwie aus, aus, irgendwo aus dem Osten.
Und der hat glaube ich über 3 Stunden Anfahrt.
Einfach.
Also er wäre quasi 6 Stunden unterwegs.
Plus normal 8 Stunden Arbeit.
Wie willst du das eigentlich machen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und für den würde das ohne Homeoffice gar nicht funktionieren.
Wie soll das klappen?
Struggles offside working remote.
Okay.
Okay, was ist so der größte Struggle...
Was heißt Struggle direkt übersetzt?
Hürde?
Hürde vielleicht?
Schwierigkeiten?
Hürde?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was Struggle direkt übersetzt heißt.
Kampf.
Na Kampf trifft es jetzt aber nicht so wirklich.
Ja.
Ich würde es mal mit Hürden, ich würde es mal mit Hürden übersetzen.
Schwierigkeiten, Hürden so.
Unplugging after work.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Fall.
Aber das Problem habe ich schon immer, dass ich...
Deswegen ist es auch immer gut, wenn ich unter der Woche abends streame, weil dann kann ich nicht daran denken.
Gerade wenn ich irgendwas am Basteln bin.
Ich habe schon total oft gesehen, dass ich mich dann einfach mal schnell nochmal remote einlogge um 20 Uhr.
Und gucke irgendwie, wie weit irgendwas ist im Lauf.
Ob es nicht abgebrochen ist und sowas.
Und das schreibe ich dann auch meistens nicht auf.
Also insofern, ja das stimmt schon.
Das ist aber sowohl remote als auch vor Ort.
Sag mal so, wenn du die Möglichkeit hast nicht remote zu arbeiten, dann entfällt die Möglichkeit.
Nachzugucken.
Natürlich von daheim.
Aber das stimmt, das stimmt schon ein bisschen.
Das stimmt schon ein bisschen.
Ja.
Distractions at home.
Ich habe at home weniger Distractions als auf der Arbeit.
Einsamkeit, dafür habe ich den Chat.
Community, gell, Chat.
Staying motivated habe ich daheim gar kein Problem.
Ich fühle mich motivierter daheim als auf der Arbeit.
Also wenn schon, würde ich das hier sagen.
Wenn schon, würde ich das hier sagen.
Ansonsten.
Seriously, das ist was, was ich nicht ganz verstehe.
Ich meine, ja, man sieht Leute auf der Arbeit.
Aber es ist jetzt.
Ich meine, es ist umso besser, wenn man sich gut versteht mit den Leuten.
Auf der Arbeit.
Okay.
Ja.
Aber es.
Das ist genauso wie wenn mein alter Arbeitgeber hat gesagt.
Ja, wir müssen ja die Leute zurück ins Büro holen, weil wir haben als Arbeitgeber ja auch eine Fürsorgepflicht.
Und wir möchten ja nicht, dass die Leute zu Hause vereinsamen, wo ich mir so immer denke.
Leute, man kann auch schlicht und ergreifend nach der Arbeit einfach noch rausgehen, wenn man Bock drauf hat.
Das ist das.
Das verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Ich meine, es zwingt mich doch keiner.
Vom Rechner hocken.
Vom Rechner hocken zu bleiben, wenn es mir nach Interaktion draußen irgendwie wäre.
Das Ding ist.
Mir ist es meistens nicht nach großer sozialer Interaktion.
Ja.
Aber wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt denken würde, ey, ich müsste ich mal raus und für Gammel.
Dann.
Es hält mich.
Es zwingt mich ja niemand nach der Arbeit vom Rechner sitzen zu bleiben.
Außerdem wenn du zwei Tage, wenn du zwei Stunden am Tag Zeit sparst.
Kannst du dich vielleicht nach der Arbeit noch oder hast du vielleicht Bock, nach der Arbeit dich noch ein bisschen zu bewegen.
Was insgesamt für das gesamte Wohlbefinden und Gesundheit besser ist.
Mit der Fürsorge.
Das ist so eines der Standard.
Das ist eines der Standard.
Und das nächste ist.
Kennt ihr diesen Spruch auch?
Den haben sie bei mir in der der beim alten Arbeitgeber immer gebracht.
Wir arbeiten hier von Menschen und mit.
Nee.
Wie haben sie es immer gesagt?
Fuck ich von Menschen für Menschen oder irgendwie so einen blöden Spruch haben sie immer gebracht.
Von Menschen für Menschen und sowas haben sie immer gesagt.
Da musste ich immer richtig cringen, wo ich, wo ich gedacht habe Alter.
Wo arbeite ich von und für und mit und so Menschen großartig.
Also mein Linux Terminal ist sehr menschlich.
Und das, was ich an Interaktion brauche, geht über Teams.
Tatsächlich viel einfacher.
Und angenehmer.
Das ist das ist tatsächlich so.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Das.
Das, das sehe ich auch so.
In welcher sozialen Einrichtung hast du gearbeitet?
Glücklicherweise arbeite ich in gar keiner sozialen Einrichtung.
Die einzige soziale Einrichtung, der ich je gearbeitet habe, war mal eine Behindertenwerkstatt.
Während ich Zivildienst gemacht habe.
Und da muss ich sagen, so im Nachhinein betrachtet.
Ich hatte übelste Berührungsängste am Anfang.
Ich habe mich immer wieder so verletzt.
Ich habe immer wieder so ein bisschen nachgeschaut.
Und das ist mir immer noch nicht mehr aufgefallen.
Weil ich, ich habe niemanden gesehen, der mich mit den Leuten berührt hat.
Was weiß ich.
Und ich finde, da habe ich mich so.
Kann ich nicht mehr haben.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir da was sagen.
Ich bin dabei.
Ja, ich sehe auch schon.
Da ist es noch nicht
fast.
Nein, leider.
Ja, es kommt auf jeden Fall soccer ab.
Ja, ich habe es auch schon.
Aber ich kann mich nicht mehr vorstellen, dass ich das nicht bedenke.
Es ist ganz schön aufregend.
Aber es geht mir nicht ums Leben.
Ich kann es mir nicht mal vorstellen, dass ich das nicht mache.
Ich kann es mich nicht mehr vorstellen.
Könnte ich mir im Leben nicht vorstellen
Ja gut, wenn es kein Teams und nichts gibt
Ist natürlich blöd, aber ich labere täglich
Gefühlt eh die Hälfte
Der Zeit auf irgendwelchen Meetings mit Leuten
Also insofern, das ist sogar
Viel angenehmer bei Teams
Da kannst du es mal kurz aufs Handy switchen
Und zwischendurch aufs Klo gehen, das Handy neben dich legen
Wenn du gerade nichts sagen musst
Also biggest struggle haben wir auch
Okay, wenn man längere Zeiten
Remote gearbeitet hat, ob man sich dann
Mehr oder weniger connected mit den
Coworkers fühlt, seriously
Soll ich euch mal
Ernsthaft
Meine ehrliche Meinung dazu sagen
Ich fühle mich entweder
No impact oder more connected
Tatsächlich, weil es über Teams
Viel einfacher ist
Leute zu erreichen und zu sagen
Ey lass mal kurz gucken
Wie sieht es denn aus, die fragen dich kurz
Hier Max, guck mal, ich habe ein Problem
Keine Ahnung, mit SE Linux
Hier mit damit, mit Git
Können wir mal zusammen gucken, dann gucken wir mal schnell
Das ist viel einfacher, als wenn du
Irgendwie in einem Büro hockst
Und die Leute am Telefonieren
Sind dabei und denen auf den Sack gehst
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde entweder sagen
Zum größten Teil no impact
Aber in einzelnen Fällen
Tatsächlich more
Connected
Hängt aber auch immer mit den anderen
Leuten zusammen, wie gut die das machen
Du brauchst noch ein Soundbite
Von den Teams Notification, meinst du das hier?
Habe ich schon
Productivity and work performance
Okay
Ob sich die Leute
Produktiver oder weniger
Produktiver als im Office
Fühlen
Wenn sie von zu Hause arbeiten
Darkzone HD, danke für den Sub
Lass mich mal kurz schauen, dass ich nicht für die Hälfte vergessen habe
An Subscribers
Subscriber
Ne, habe ich nicht
Weiß
So, Lothar Nox, danke für den Sub
Weißt du eigentlich
Dass du rückwärts Xonatol heißt?
Warum auch immer
Nicht, dass das irgendwas bedeuten würde
Also
Ich fühle mich
Deutlich mehr produktiv daheim
Und ich merke das auch immer
Wenn ich
Im Office bin, dass ich nichts
Geschissen bekomme
Wenn die Leute sich selbst bewerten dürfen
Entscheiden sie sich mehr für
Produktive, wie kommst du denn drauf
Dass die Leute absichtlich das falsch bewerten würden
Oder verstehe ich dich jetzt nicht
Richtig
Bei anonymen Unfragen gibt es doch überhaupt keinen Sinn
Irgendwelchen Blödsinn zu erzählen
Ich würde das prinzipiell einfach mal glauben
Wenn die Leute das so bewerten
Und es gibt ja sogar
Es gibt ja sogar Studien dazu
Wenn du Leute im Vorfeld fragst
Wie sie sich einschätzen
Realistisch
Dass die Einschätzung sehr oft tatsächlich
Nah an das kommt, wie sie auch eingeschätzt werden
Also ich könnte das voll und ganz unterschreiben
Wenn ich jeden Tag ins Büro müsste
Würde ich nicht sagen, dass ich das so bewerten würde
Würde ich nur die Hälfte hinkriegen
Das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben
Das ganze multige Taske
Und drei Sachen gleichzeitig
Kriegst du im Büro gar nicht hin
Arbeiten sie mehr oder weniger
Seit man Remote arbeiten kann
Also ich versuche ungefähr das gleiche zu arbeiten
Also wir gehen jetzt nicht davon aus, wie viel man schafft
Sondern reine Arbeitszeit
Ich versuche ungefähr das gleiche zu arbeiten
Aber meine Zeiterfassung sagt
Dass es insgesamt mehr wird
Was aber auch daran liegt
Dass ich jetzt nicht mehr nach Zugankunft
Und Abfahrtszeit
Gehen muss
Sondern einfach ganz normal
7 bis 15 oder 30 oder 16 Uhr
Arbeite
Weil ich eben die Zeit spare
Was nice ist
Und auch alle was von haben
Sollen die Leute schwätzen
Oder sollen die Leute was schaffen
Genau die gleiche Aussage hast du von manch anderen Chef
So nach dem Motto
Also es ist immer die Frage
Auf was man Wert legt
Also ich persönlich kann darauf verzichten
Jeden Tag
Irgendwie zu arbeiten
Irgendwie durchs Büro zu gehen
Und mit den Leuten zu reden
Wie es beim Skifahren war oder sowas
Mit den Leuten mit denen ich mich gut verstehe
Und im Teams hocke
Labern wir eh nebenbei mal ein bisschen
So nach dem Motto
Schon das neue CS ausprobiert
Oder sonst was in der Richtung
Aber ansonsten
Braucht es eigentlich kein Mensch so
Von irgendwelchen Leuten
Die ich gefühlt einmal im Monat sehe
Muss ich nicht wissen wie der letzte Skiurlaub war
Das ist auch so
Und man sieht es ja auch ganz klar
Die Unternehmen die Homeoffice anbieten
Es muss ja auch nicht 100% Homeoffice sein
Die bekommen Leute
Und die Leute und die Unternehmen die kein Homeoffice anbieten
Bekommen keine Leute
Umgedreht natürlich Gehalt auch
Also die die gutes Gehalt und Homeoffice anbieten
Haben viel viel bessere Chancen Leute zu bekommen
Als die die kein Homeoffice und schlechtes Gehalt anbieten
Leute wie seht ihr das
Sagt Radiosignale
Ich dreh durch wenn ich im Homeoffice bin
Und jemand sitzt an meinem Arbeitsplatz
Und benutzt meinen Tastatur
Das mag ich auch nicht
Deswegen ganz einfach
Bei uns ist es so
Also kommt auf das Büro an
Aber dort wo ich meistens sitze
Sind Wechselarbeitsplätze
Dort nimmst du alles wieder mit
Die haben zwar an dem Arbeitsplatz
Eine Tastatur und Maus
Stehen
Aber ich habe meine eigene Tastatur und Maus
Die liegt im Schrank
Die schließe ich dann immer an
Und bringe sie abends wieder in den Schrank
Bevor ich abhaue
Das kann ich auch echt nur empfehlen
Nimm eine eigene Maus
Und eine eigene Tastatur mit
Die du magst
Ich habe immer noch meine Ducky One
Skyline
Heißt die so
Ducky One Skyline
Die erste habe ich noch
Mit Numblock und allem
Und eine Logitech G502
Und die habe ich seit Jahren schon
Die hatte ich auch im letzten Job schon
Und die werden einfach abgestöpselt abends
Und wieder in den Schrank gelegt
Und hast du schon gelevelt
Ähm
Also ich finde das
Finde das sinnig
Wenn man eine eigene Tastatur und Maus hat
Hä echt
Also bei uns sind die super krass pingelig
Was das angeht
Aber gegen eine eigene Tastatur haben die nix
Eine was für eine Tastatur
Oh das ist eine ohne Numblock
Ohne Numblock und
Und Error Keys
Das kann ich nicht gebrauchen
Doch Error Keys hast du
Aber da hat die komische
Okay das ne das mag ich nicht
Kein Numblock und komische Enter Taste
Es ist Geschmackssache sicherlich
Aber ich persönlich mag Full Size Keyboards
Mit Numblock
Mit abgesetzten Error Keys
Mit Bild hoch, Bild runter, POS 1, Ende
An der normalen Stelle
Ja
FF Tasten und alles
Und auch ein bisschen abgesetzt oben
Es ist Geschmackssache
Aber ich mag es einfach nicht
So kleine Tastatur
Ups
Oh guck mal ich hab meine VM gestartet
Ich mach mal kurz Package Update
Arch by the way
Wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben
Ah das hatten wir
Oh fuck wie viel kommt denn da noch
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen schneller sein
Sonst wird das ja heute mit dem
Mit Youtube Videos gucken
Wir gehen erstmal da im schnellen Durchgang drüber
Ich mach mal schnell Package Update
Weil gucken vielleicht
Heute Mittag ein bisschen Bastel
Wir machen heute Mittag kein Advent of Code
Wir machen glaube ich ein bisschen Bastel
Ein bisschen Bastelstelz
Check for Updates, Update all
Zack Pac-Man
Massive geheimes Passwort kommt hier nie drauf
Was meint ihr was mein Passwort ist
Timochi
Boggers
Endlich
Timochi 15 ist am Start
Massive
Nice
Wisst ihr was
Wisst ihr was das heißt
Das heißt
Wir haben nach dem Update endlich
Das Enten
Nicht das Enten
Das Gänse Emoji
Das Enten
Nicht das Enten
Das Gänse Emoji
Kommt das jetzt hier her Timochi
Ja die haben geupdatet
Timochi 15
Nice
Und die Gans ist auch dabei
Pog
Endlich
Da hab ich drauf gewartet
Ganz wichtig
Richtig und wichtig
Genau
So wir müssen kurz warten bis Pacman da oben durch ist
Ryder ist auch gleich geupdatet
So
So auf
So auf Pacman mach hin
Wie ich einfach bei einem Package Update komplette CPU Auslastung habe
So
Jetzt machen wir noch Package Updates
Now we are doing another Package Updates
from the user repos
Hasst du was verpasst
Yeah
Endlich wieder einen gescheiten Color-Emoji-Font für Linux, der auf dem aktuellen Stand ist.
Ich meine, bald steht, glaube ich, schon Unicode 16 in den Startlöchern.
Es gibt noch nicht so wirklich viel, kommt auch erst 2000, ja, dauert noch, aber wie gesagt, steht schon in den Startlöchern.
Und es gibt schon neue Emojis, die wohl included werden.
Zum Beispiel, Root Vegetable und Shovel, ganz wichtig.
Face with Back Under Eyes, das gibt es noch keine Implementierung von.
Nein, ich suche eigentlich das Emote.
Das kommt mit Unicode 16.
Haben wir das hier fertig?
Massive geheimes Passwort, auf das ihr nie kommt.
Ich glaube, wir müssen...
Warum finde ich nicht das Goose-Emoji?
Ah, weil es mein Geheimnis ist.
Weil es mein Clipboard ist, lul.
Da ist es, Leute!
Bam!
Die ganze ist am Starren.
Nice.
Okay, was für neue Emojis?
Emojis, Emojis, Unicode 15.
Was gab es da Neues?
Gleich mal checken, ob du es findest.
Shaking Face, Shaking...
Alter, ich muss...
Shaking Face.
Okay, nice.
Endlich.
Mein Browser hat es noch nicht gecheckt, weil ich den noch nicht neu gestartet habe.
Und...
Und ein Elch.
Ein Elch ist jetzt auch dabei.
Excellent, excellent.
So, da würde ich sagen, es wird mal Zeit, zu rebooten.
Damit das alles aktiv wird.
Sehr schön.
Endlich.
Da wurde es echt Zeit.
Twimoji 15.
Ja, warum ich mich so sehr darüber freue, ist...
Twimoji wurde eingestampft.
Also ursprünglich ist Twimoji...
Also, die sind quasi die Emoji-Bilder genommen von Twitter.
Und in einen Font, in eine Schriftart gepackt.
Was man halt braucht, dass man Emojis anzeigen kann.
Und als Elon Twitter übernommen hat, hat er einfach alle Leute rausgeschmissen, die sich um Twimoji gekümmert haben.
Dementsprechend gab es jetzt lange Zeit einfach kein neues Twimoji.
Und ehemalige Twitter-Mitarbeiter und Community-Leute auf GitHub und vor allem Discord,
weil Discord verwendet den Font auch,
haben jetzt Contributed, Twimoji 15 zu erstellen.
Die jetzt leicht andere Bilder haben zu Twitter,
weil die neuen Twitter-Emojis halt nicht mehr Open Source sind.
Also sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr nice.
So, wichtigste Sachen.
Wichtigste Sachen gehen auch immer noch.
Sehr gut, AskIquarium läuft.
GIFs im Terminal funktionieren auch noch.
Also, alles klar, alles gut.
Update war erfolgreich.
Okay, gehen wir mal kurz zu dieser Studie da.
Wieder eine Studiumfrage ist es ja nicht.
Umfrage zurück.
Okay, wie popular sind...
Was?
Achso, da sind jetzt Statistiken von denen ihrer Seite, ja.
Okay, Remote Jobs sind etwas mehr beliebt als Non-Remote Jobs.
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
Okay, AI skippen wir einfach mal.
Wobei, ganz kurz, wir gucken mal, wie verbreitet das hier ist.
Wie viel wird AI benutzt in meinem Job?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass...
relativ wenig also ich würde ich würde mal sagen yes to some extent ja 46 also
es wird mal ab und zu eine config datei in chat gpt gedingst und aber aber zum
größten teil ich bin zum ich bin immer noch ein stack overflow enjoyer
beziehungsweise suchmaschinen reddit und stack overflow enjoyer ich habe immer
noch den eindruck ich komme ich schneller mit zum ziel als chat gpt
fragen aber das könnte sich in zukunft natürlich verschieben
bei uns auf der arbeit haben sie sich die haben sie sich eine eigene version
von chat gpt gekauft von microsoft bei microsoft bietet microsoft azure
cognitive services oder so heißt das da kann man quasi chat gpt kaufen in
azure und das haben die gemacht also wir haben theoretisch eine eigene chat gpt
geschichte wo wir ohne probleme interne config files rein passen dürfen weil wir
versuchen die gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt gpt
vertrauen ja microsoft das ist nicht public so das haben sie gesagt ich
würde das nicht machen aber ich habe das nicht entschieden
microsoft vertrauen keck wait gut chat denkt ihr dass in den nächsten fünf
jahren euren job machen könnte also ich bin relativ stark davon überzeugt nein
ich denke aber dass in einigen bereichen immer mehr ki gestützt
tools und ki gestützte abläufe und so was an den stellen wo es sinnvoll ist
sich etabliert werden aber so dieses wie es wie es noch anfang letztes jahr war
wo das so der hype so groß war wir werden alle überflüssig das glaube ich
jetzt erst mal nicht radiosignale das glaube ich auch das hast du schön
ausgedrückt ja das glaube ich auch an vielen stellen gar nicht how useful ist
a generated code naja ja musst du auch
Musst du auch einfach copy-pasten, bringt nix.
Das bringt höchstens was für irgendwelche Prototyp-Geschichten.
Ich hab letztens zum Beispiel was gesehen, der dir aus Konzeptzeichnungen HTML und CSS erstellt.
Das finde ich ganz gut, wenn du wirklich ganz schnell irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegen musst.
Warum nicht?
Recruitment-Prozess.
Why and when do we change jobs?
Okay.
Was, wo habt ihr bisher am längsten gearbeitet?
Also es geht nicht drin, ob man im aktuellen Job so lange, so insgesamt am längsten gearbeitet.
Ich war tatsächlich mehr als 10 Jahre dort bei dem Laden, bei der Bank, wo ich davor war.
Und glücklicherweise hab ich die Jubiläumsfeier gedodged.
Das war so, letztes Jahr hatte ich Jubiläumsfeier.
Ne, das stimmt gar nicht.
Vorletztes Jahr hatte ich Jubiläumsfeier, da war ich sogar 11 Jahre am Start.
Vorletztes Jahr hatte ich Jubiläumsfeier, Ende des Jahres.
Für 10 Jahre, für 10 Jahre.
Und da wirst du immer eingeladen zu irgendeinem Offline-Event und dann ist dann auch irgendwie einer vom Vorstand dabei und der IT-Chef dabei und so.
Da hab ich überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Das wurde aber abgesagt, weil Corona.
Und dann wurde ich letztes Jahr eingeladen zur Jubiläumsfeier.
Aber da war mir schon klar, dass ich kündigen werde.
Und dann hab ich auch gekündigt und dann bin ich dann da auch nicht hin.
Dann hab ich nochmal gedodget.
Jubiläumsfeier, gedodget.
It's easy.
Weil da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf gehabt, auf IT-Vorstand, Smalltalk, 3 Stunden.
Also ich war tatsächlich mehr als 10 Jahre beim letzten Laden.
Und jetzt bin ich fast schon wieder ein Jahr beim neuen.
Geht schnell rum die Zeit, ne?
Okay, was denkt ihr ist der hauptsächliche Grund, um einen neuen Job in Erwägung zu ziehen?
Was machst du beruflich?
Ich hab auf YouTube ein Video zu, wo ich das ausführlich erkläre.
Aber mach mal Ausrufezeichen Job.
Ich glaube, wir haben auch eine halbwegs sinnige Erklärung im Chat.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen. Probieren wir mal, ob das Ausrufezeichen gibt. Gibt's da nicht was?
Haben wir da nicht ein...
Oh.
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja outdated as fuck.
Modcheck.
Modcheck. Kann man das irgendwie anpassen?
Eric versucht, seine Arbeit zu erklären.
Alter!
Kann ich hier runterscrollen, ohne dass was passiert?
boobs
So, ich versuch, meinen Job zu erklären.
heißt, was ich mache.
Egal, ich sag dir,
was ich aktuell mache. Also aktuell kümmere ich
mich hauptsächlich um Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Wo ist denn hier derjenige, der das gefragt hat?
Ja, da ist das hier.
Also ich kümmere mich aktuell hauptsächlich
um Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber war es Azure, beim neuen Arbeitgeber
ist es Google.
Und dort um Linux-Kisten,
Automatisierung und vor allem
Kubernetes-Cluster und Containerisierung
und Image-Bauen
und automatisches Erstellen von Infrastruktur
mit Terraform.
Also könnte man quasi zusammenfassen so als
könnte man das zusammenfassen
so ein bisschen Richtung DevOps.
Ich habe auch schon kleine Tools programmiert
wieder. So ein bisschen Richtung DevOps.
Auch wenn ich bei der alten Stelle
hatte ich ja tatsächlich DevOps-Engineer im Titel.
Bei der neuen nicht.
Bei der neuen bin ich Linux-Engineer.
Wobei es
es ist zwar alles mit Linux-Bezug,
aber zum Großteil
eher Infrastruktur-Management
drumherum.
Also würde ich mal
sagen, es geht schon so
in DevOps-Bereich.
Also es ist aber natürlich auch schon viel Linux.
Wir haben ja auch noch einige Kisten, die
bei uns im Rechenzentrum laufen.
Aber es ist hauptsächlich eher
Cloud-Automatisierung und
Infrastruktur zur Zeit.
Site-Reliability-Engineer.
Okay, das weiß ich nicht, ob das
so ein Buzzword ist. Das kenne ich, aber
weiß nicht, ob das das trifft.
Ja, das mache ich gerade.
Aber ich glaube, die haben das ganz gut
weggesteckt. Jeder ist irgendwie ersetzlich
ersetzbar.
Ich habe aber gehört, dass die, also ich habe ja noch
Kontakt mit denen. Ich habe aber gehört, dass die einige
Probleme haben jetzt.
Gerade mit ihren
regelmäßigen
Infrastruktur und sonst was
Releases. Das, was ich mich da zum größten Teil
drum gekümmert habe.
Sodass sie sich das jetzt irgendwie einteilen müssen.
Dass das Leute nachts machen und irgendwie.
Also, da muss wohl nicht alles so
glatt laufen, aber die kriegen das auch wohl ganz gut ohne mich hin.
Hast du studiert? Ich habe eine normale
Ausbildung gemacht. Ich habe 2007
habe ich
Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration gelernt.
Bei einem
kleineren Internet-Provider. Also es war nicht die
Telekom oder sonst was.
Nichts, was man kennt.
Stubenmorger, danke für den Sub.
Moin, haben wir eine Ausbildung vor einem
Jahr als Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwicklung
abgeschlossen? Wurde von einem Unternehmen?
Äh, von, wurde von dem Unternehmen
übernommen.
Willst du jetzt wechseln und mich auf eine Junior-Stelle
bewerben? Weißt du, wie so ein Bewerbungsprozess
auf eine Junior-Stelle ist? Oder weißt du,
also, die Bewerbung, der Bewerbungsprozess
an sich, der wird sich nicht großartig
unterscheiden
zu einer normalen, zu einer Nicht-Junior-Stelle.
Sie werden dir vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger tiefgreifende Fragen
stellen. Kommt drauf an, ob das,
ob die Personalabteilung da überhaupt
einen Plan hat, was
der Unterschied ist.
Also, wie so ein Bewerbungsprozess
aussieht, hängt ganz entscheidend von dem jeweiligen
Unternehmen ab. Also, was ich, ich kann dir
nur sagen, was ich, wie es bei mir, wie es bei mir
gewesen ist, ja. Also,
was, was zur Zeit relativ beliebt ist,
dass man, wenn die Bewerbung passt,
dass man
erstmal online
so einen, so einen First, wie
nennt man das so, erstes Kennenlerngespräch macht,
online über Teams, da kriegst du dann einen Einladungslink
geschickt, keine Ahnung,
Freitag, 14 Uhr,
Chatraum, kannst du dann,
kannst du dann reinjoinen. Übrigens,
ich hab nen Bug gefunden, als ich online
mein Vorstellungsgespräch hatte,
bei dem Laden, wo ich jetzt nicht
angefangen hab, und zwar,
ich mach's ja immer so, ich joine mit
dem Handy rein, in so Teams-Calls
für die Kamera
und mit dem Desktop,
dass ich mein ordentliches Audio-Equipment
hab. Und da bin ich in den, in den Teams-Call
gejoined, mit dem Handy
und Microsoft hat es
irgendwie geschafft, dass die Abfrage,
ob man schon in den Call joinen
darf, auf dem Handy nicht funktioniert.
Und ich war in dem Call, schon
drinne, bevor die Personalabteilung in dem
Call drinne war, obwohl das eigentlich so
nen Teams-Raum gewesen ist, wo
die Personalabteilung oder derjenige, der dieses
Meeting eingeladen hat, explizit
anhaken muss,
äh, Meeting startet jetzt, ihr kennt das vielleicht.
Da sind dann so Meeting-Räume, wo drinsteht,
äh, vier Leute warten
darauf, dass das Meeting startet und sowas.
Und ich war dann schon drinne, bevor die Personalabteilung
reingejoined ist, was sie irgendwie alle
sichtlich verwirrt hat. Ja, da
gibt's dann online meistens so ein erstes Kennenlernen,
und wenn man sich dann da versteht, wirst du
wahrscheinlich mal vor Ort eingeladen
und da kriegste dann die üblichen Fragen gestellt,
die Personalabteilung
gerne so stellen, je nachdem wie die drauf
sind. Also,
schwer, schwer zu sagen, kommt
bisschen auf das Unternehmen an.
Und, und du solltest dich auf jeden Fall schon mal
im Vorfeld
Gedanken drüber machen, was du als Gehaltsvorstellung
sagst. Das ist ja leider
immer noch so, dass das nicht
vorgeschrieben ist, dass das angegeben
werden muss. Ich bin mir einig, hab
irgendwo letztens gelesen, dass es jetzt eine Regelung
geben soll, dass das Pflicht
wird. Da bin ich aber
skeptisch, inwieweit das
eingehalten wird, weil
im Zweifelsfall kannst du einfach reinschreiben
Gehaltsspanne 1000 Euro
bis eine Million. Ja, gut, nice.
Weißt du genau so
viel, so viel und wenig
wie davor. Zumindest
solltest du dich auf die Frage schon mal vorbereiten.
Und du weißt ja,
besser
bisschen zu viel sagen, als zu wenig.
Ich hab mal vor
Jahren einen Talk
gesehen auf YouTube, der das ganz
gut beschrieben hat. Was sollte man
sagen bei Gehaltsverhandlungen?
Man sollte immer den Betrag
sagen, der einem
kurz vor unverschämt
erscheint.
Und ich finde, das ist echt
ein guter Rat gewesen.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben,
aber
letztendlich werden
sie eh immer erzählen, oh das ist etwas
außerhalb der Gehaltsspanne.
Also es ist besser, sie werden erst mal
sich ein bisschen rumdrücken mit, oh das ist aber
leicht außerhalb unserer Gehaltsspanne, bla bla bla.
Als wenn sie sagen, jawoll
passt. Also wenn du sofort hörst,
jawoll passt, kannst du
von ausgehen, du hast zu wenig gesagt.
Also ich kann dir sagen, was ich
gesagt habe und wie die Reaktion da
drauf war. Ich hab mir das im Vorfeld
überlegt, was sagst du als
Gehaltswunsch? Sagst
du schon mal ordentliche
Hausnummer? Weil es muss sich ja auch lohnen.
Wenn man wechselt und letztendlich
ganze Einarbeitung und Stress und drum herum, irgendwie
muss sich das ja auch lohnen. Sagst du
was? Ich habe am Anfang, ich bin mir nicht
hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich bin relativ
sicher, ich habe gesagt, ich
hätte gern 115.000 Euro.
Auf fünf Tage
gerechnet, 115.000 Euro.
Und da haben die gemeint, ah das
ist, und da war halt genau die gleiche Reaktion
drauf, ah das ist aber
leicht außerhalb unserer
unseres Gehaltgefüges
und da kam halt
die üblichen, da kamen halt die üblichen Antworten
so nach dem Motto, ja wir müssen ja auch auf
die interne Gehaltsstruktur
achten und
ähm, da können wir
jetzt nicht so viel und drüber und drunter
und ah und nö und nö und
war natürlich klar, dass das nicht
funktioniert. Wie gesagt, ich hab gesagt, man soll immer
kurz vor unverschämt sagen,
wobei ich sagen muss, das war jetzt,
ja, also
es schien mir als,
werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen, aber
kann man mal, kann man mal sagen, ja.
Ich mein, es ist immerhin eine Seniorstelle mit
15, 15 Jahren plus Erfahrung,
da kann man schon mal bissl, bissl was,
bissl was drauf, bissl was verlangen, ja.
So. Kurz vor unverschämt
ist das, wo du Bauchschmerzen kriegst.
So und
am Ende kam es dann halt darauf raus,
dass es weniger gibt,
aber dadurch, dass es Bonus gibt und
ähm, Sonderzahlung und Zulagen,
dass es doch so
ungefähr in die Richtung
geht. Also.
Passt doch alles. Ja, im
Vertrag steht natürlich bedeutend weniger als
115k drin. Ich glaub,
ich glaub im Vertrag stehen,
ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher,
ich glaub im Vertrag stehen 92k oder
95k, die zwei
Zahlen schwirren mir gerade im Kopf rum.
Ich glaub, ich glaub 92k stehen im
Vertrag drinne.
Kann auch 95k sein, aber
das ist halt, das ist ganz weird, weird
champig berechnet.
Das ist quasi so das Mindeste.
Ohne, dass es jetzt irgendwie
zuschnittlich Bonus gebe, ohne
Sonderzahlung, ohne Rufbereitschaft,
Zulage und sonst was. Das heißt,
wenn das noch, wenn das noch oben drauf kommt,
dann geht das so ungefähr in die
Richtung. Aber ich bekomme ja eh nicht so
viel, ich bekomme ja eh nicht so viel,
weil ich arbeite ja nur vier Tage
die Woche. Aber ich
hab's auf fünf Tage die Woche gesagt, weil
niemand rechnet
im Kopf 80% davon aus.
Also so kannst du dir das ungefähr
vorstellen. Mach dich auf jeden Fall
drauf gefasst, dass du gefragt wirst nach deiner
Gehalt, nach deinem Gehaltswunsch
und mach dich auch drauf gefasst, dass du ein bisschen
was zur Arbeit gefragt wirst, beziehungsweise
auch zum
zum Umfeld des Unternehmens
irgendwie. Natürlich, wenn du Pech hast,
hast du Leute von der Personalabteilung dabei
sitzen, die irgendwelche, ja so
so blöde, offene
Fragen stellen, so nach dem Motto
wie viel, wie viele Smarties passen
in einen Smart oder sowas.
Oder aber auch
wo sehen sie sich
in zehn Jahren?
Oder was sie
bei mir gefragt haben. Was müssten
wir machen, um sie so richtig aufzuregen?
Oder welche
Tipps würden sie einer angehenden
Führungskraft geben? So komische Dinger.
Also stell dich mal ein bisschen drauf ein, dass du die
ein oder anderen etwas offenen
weirden Fragen gestellt kriegst.
Antworte da einfach
möglichst diplomatisch drauf
und gut ist.
Also du musst nicht bei allem 100%
immer bei deinem
Bauchgefühl und bei der
Wahrheit, so wie du es selbst siehst,
bleiben. Also wenn du
offensichtlich raushörst aus dem Bewerbungsgespräch,
dass die XYZ
toll finden und du persönlich
findest XYZ
total scheiße, dann würde
ich das nicht unbedingt so sagen.
Weil du könntest es vielleicht
formulieren mit, ja es gibt ja auch noch andere
Frameworks, die ich mag, aber
ich kann mich in alles
einarbeiten oder irgendwas.
Ah ja.
Du hast noch den Vorteil, dass du vorher schon
in Frankfurt gearbeitet hast. Stell dir mal vor.
Ah ja.
Da muss er bei mir
im Stream gucken. Community
Appurett
bezieht Bürgergeld. Habe ich gestern schon
gehört, ja. Aber ich habe das Video
nicht geguckt und ich werde mir das Video auch nicht angucken,
aber ich habe schon vernommen,
ja. Läuft
der INSI-Modus noch?
Also ich habe,
wisst ihr was ich, ihr wisst das, ich habe es euch schon
erzählt. Wisst ihr was ich darauf geantwortet habe?
Was müssen wir machen, um sie so richtig
aufzuregen? Ich habe gesagt, Windows
administrieren. Als Antwort
kam dann nur, ja, nicht so fachlich
orientiert, sondern eher so
ich weiß
gar nicht mehr, was sie genau gesagt haben.
Windows administrieren.
Okay, dann lass uns mal weiter.
Wir haben immer, ich bin fast
zwei Stunden und wir haben immer noch nichts auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Also was hatten wir denn hier? Why and when
do we change jobs? Also hier,
was ist die Haupt, das ist tatsächlich
Ups, warum habe ich jetzt eigentlich gemutet?
Was ist der Hauptgrund, warum die Leute
es in Erwägung ziehen, ihre Arbeit zu
zu changen?
Arbeit zu changen?
Also wann wird
hauptsächlich die Arbeit gechanged, Leute?
Dann
hauptsächlicher Grund ist Gehalt.
Das hätte ich mir fast schon gedacht.
No remote home office
hätte ich mir auch schon gedacht. Poor management
hätte ich mir auch schon gedacht.
Also bei mir würde ich tatsächlich
sagen, beim alten Arbeitgeber war das eine
Mischung aus den ersten drei.
Gehalt war nicht schlecht, hätte durchaus
mehr sein können. Management
war zum größten Teil, 70%
der Leute komplett unfähigst
as fuck und
immer mehr Probleme, was Homeoffice
und Flexibilität angeht.
Das war eine Kombination aus den
drei, ich habe ja auch Videos dazu gemacht,
aus den drei, dass
der Mittaggrund war,
dass ich keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte.
Und wisst ihr, was bezeichnet war bei meinem
alten Job?
Ich hatte dort so ein Exit-Interview
und in diesem Exit-Interview soll
laut Beschreibung
geklärt werden, was denn jetzt die Gründe
dafür waren,
dass man keinen Bock
mehr auf den Laden hat.
Und ich habe mir im Vorfeld extra
drei, vier Sachen aufgeschrieben,
ich habe mir gedacht, machen wir das mal.
Drei, vier Sachen aufgeschrieben, unter anderem
war das ein großer Punkt bei mir,
wo ich gesagt hätte,
so, und
das Witzige war,
die Frau von der Personalabteilung
hatte überhaupt keinen Bock, dieses Exit,
dieses Exit-Interview zu machen.
Die ist da einfach durchgerusht
und hat bei manchen Fragen,
da gab es unter anderem so Fragen, so
was, was, was, wenn sie könnten, was würden
sie verbessern und sowas.
Und die Fragen hat die einfach geskippt.
Die hat dann gemeint,
ah, das ist jetzt nicht so relevant, machen wir weiter
mit der nächsten Frage.
Und das hat mich mal wieder daran bestätigt,
eines der größten Punkte,
die mir beim alten Arbeitgeber
auf den Sack gegangen sind,
die Diskrepanz zwischen
was erzählt wird
und was gemacht wird.
So nach dem Motto,
es werden Umfragen durchgeführt,
wenn das Ergebnis nicht passt,
werden die Ergebnisse aber nie angesprochen,
weil man weiß ja um seine Schwächen und sowas.
Das war eines der größten Sachen,
die mir dort auf den Keks ging
und das hat sich selbst beim Exit-Interview
wieder bestätigt,
und das ist auch exakt in der Beziehung.
Okay, was ist die längste Zeit,
wo ich ohne einen Job war?
Ein Jahr und mehr.
Ihr kennt meine MMO-Kreisel-Crime-Zeit.
Nach der Schule
und nach der ersten
verkackten Ausbildung
online, online
MMO-Kreisel-Crime.
Was war denn die erste verkackte Ausbildung?
BWL-Zeug, Bürokaufmann.
Kaufmann für Büroorganisation.
MonkaS,
Alter.
Nein!
Gott, bitte nein!
Das habe ich nicht lange ausgehalten.
Ja, also ich war über ein Jahr ohne Job.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange.
Kann ich mir jetzt auch
nicht so richtig zusammenreimen
mehr.
Da habe ich MMO-Kreisel-Crime gemacht.
Anfang, Anfang 2000er.
So.
Irgendwann habe ich dann Zivildienst
gemacht.
Das ist aber schon eine Weile her.
Okay, relocate interessiert mich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht.
Ah, Recruitment-Prozess.
Okay, was ist das Interessanteste
oder das Ansprechendste bei neuen Jobs?
Also,
Projekt, Gehalt,
Remote-Work-Possibility. Ja, im Prinzip
die zwei Sachen, das hatten wir ja schon.
Genau das, bei mir auch der Fall.
Ah, die Quelle
von neuen Job-Angeboten.
Brands and Networking, Recruiters,
wie sieht das bei euch aus?
Bei mir war es bisher eigentlich ausschließlich
das hier, Brands and Networking.
Obwohl ich so ein unsozialer
Kackspast bin, war es tatsächlich bei mir
zum größten Teil das hier.
Weiß nicht, wie das bei euch aussieht.
Also, als ich den Job
gewechselt bin,
das erste Vorstellungsgespräch, Interview,
Dings hatte ich tatsächlich
mit jemand, der meine YouTube-Videos guckt
und gemeint hat, Max, wir haben genau den richtigen Job für dich.
Habe ich mir mal angehört.
Ist dann nichts geworden.
Dann,
nächstes Vorstellungsgespräch
hatte ich mit einem
Ex-Kollege,
der jetzt Teamleiter ist
und Leute gesucht hat
und
aktuellen Job, wo ich dann gelandet bin, habe ich auch gefunden,
weil mich
jemand, den ich von früher noch kannte,
angesprochen hat. Der hat witzigerweise
mein Video geguckt auf YouTube und hat gesagt, ey Max,
ich habe dein Video gesehen, wir suchen gerade jemand,
gerade im Linux-Bereich,
der sich auch ein bisschen auskennt,
wäre das nicht was?
Und da hat er mir das ein bisschen schmackhaft gemacht
und das ging dann super schnell.
Ich habe ihm gesagt, ey, weißt du was,
ich schicke dir schon mal meine Bewerbungsunterlagen,
kannst ja mal gucken, ob das passt bei euch.
Und da war ich gerade letztes Jahr
im Bauhaus
Weihnachtsbaum kaufen und da hat mich
sein Chef angerufen und hat gefragt,
ja hier, Max, also Herr Max,
wie sieht es aus?
Haben Sie nächste Woche Zeit?
Ich müsste
mich halt der Form halber nochmal online
bewerben,
über ihr Jobportal
und so.
Also es war bei mir tatsächlich,
auch wenn ich, wie gesagt, so unsozialer Kackschwast bin,
aber war es tatsächlich Friends and
Networking mit den Jobs bisher.
Recruitment-Prozess.
Welcher, okay,
welcher von einem
Bewerbungsprozess, was ist das
demotivierendste und nervigste
Okay, die meisten Leute sagen
lack of feedback,
too many interview stages,
no salary. Ja, würde ich
alle drei Sachen unterschreiben.
Also lack of feedback ist, wenn du
nie was hörst, ist nervig.
Hatte ich jetzt, zumindest beim letzten Job
suche ich nicht. Too many interview stages
hatte ich jetzt auch nicht, kann ich aber nachvollziehen.
No salary information
finde ich schon beim angucken immer nervig.
Ehrlich gesagt, ein Punkt,
der mich auch nervt
ist, den ich aber selbst glücklicherweise
nicht erlebt habe,
aber Kollege von mir hatte das,
wenn du verarscht wirst, ich erzähle
euch jetzt mal was, den haben sie richtig
verarscht. Ich glaube noch nicht mal,
dass das Unternehmen das als
Verarschung gesehen hat.
Die haben ausgeschrieben,
ich sage jetzt mal, einen Senior,
keine Ahnung,
Senior, Senior Admin,
sagen wir mal, es war kein Senior Admin, es war irgendwas anderes.
Ich sage jetzt mal, die haben einen Senior Administrator
ausgeschrieben. Kollege von mir hat sich
drauf beworben,
also ja, die haben einen Senior Admin ausgeschrieben
und da stand irgendwas, Gehaltsspanne
90 bis
105k oder sowas, irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Hat er sich drauf beworben
und die haben sich, ne ich weiß
was es war, es war kein Senior Admin, es war
ein Senior
Support Specialist
oder sowas. Ich weiß Recycle Story,
aber das haben vielleicht nicht alle gehört. Senior Support
Specialist oder sowas. Das war
auch, es hat mega gut für ihn gepasst,
weil der hat tatsächlich
mal angefangen bei uns auch
im, nicht im
Support zu arbeiten, aber im
internen so
Eskalationsmanagement,
Supportprozessdings und
das konnte er auch gut.
Und der hat
gerade bei Störungen, das war so mein Lieblings,
mit mein Lieblings so
Störungs-Change-Koordinator,
wenn was war, mit dem war das alles immer,
lief immer super,
auch alles klar und
der war sogar noch pfeifett genug,
dass der selbst Fehler
fixen konnte. Leute, wann
hattet ihr zuletzt ein
Change, beziehungsweise ein
Incident-Koordinator,
der selbst Probleme fixen
konnte? Das ist eigentlich
ne Kombination, die gibt's gar nicht.
Das liegt aber daran,
weil er früher selbst Admin war.
Das ist eigentlich nicht
möglich, ja. Und das heißt, das ist wirklich
super special, da so jemand auch
noch zu finden für die Position. Zumindest,
haben sie da geschrieben, hey,
sie haben 90 bis 105k
und da hat er
sich drauf beworben
und die haben dann auch gleich
geantwortet und haben gesagt, ey passt, alles
super, haben erstes Bewerbungsgespräch
mit ihm gemacht, remote noch,
erstes Bewerbungsgespräch
gemacht, remote, hat auch alles gepasst,
Gehalt wurde ihm auch nochmal bestätigt,
danach hatte er
ich glaube sogar vor Ort
nochmal ein Gespräch und dann
noch mal ein drittes Bewerbungsgespräch,
wo es
drum ging, ein Incident-
Case mal durchzuspielen, so nach dem Motto,
das haben die dann remote gemacht,
so nach dem Motto, es kommt ein Fehlerticket,
wie handeln sie in diesem Fall,
wenn der Vorstand sie anruft
und sagt, diese Change muss außer der
Reihe umgesetzt werden, was auch immer.
So, waren sie sich auch, waren sich alle einig,
hat gesagt, nice, super, passt, die waren mit ihm
super zufrieden, da haben sie gesagt, okay, auf geht's,
dann lasst uns
das mal angehen,
Tag, Job, sonst wie
und auf
einmal melden sie sich
oder hatten sie nochmal irgendwie ein Gespräch
mit ihm und sagen ihm, ja,
also, das mit 90 bis
105k wird nix,
das Budget gibt das leider nicht mehr her.
Es gehen bloß noch
70k, es ist leider kein Budget mehr
frei für eine Seniorstelle, haben sie ihm dann
gesagt. Und
dann hat er halt instant gesagt,
ja nö, dann nicht, tschüss.
Ich weiß halt nicht,
ich weiß halt nicht,
was mit denen los
ist. Ich mein,
seriously, du machst
drei Bewerbungsgespräche
mit jemand, ja, und du bist dir
einig, und am Ende
sagst du dem, ja, ne,
da müssen sie schon so mit 20 bis 30k
weniger auskommen. Was denken
die sich denn? Denken die jetzt, dass
die Leute sagen, oh, jetzt wo ich
schon drei Bewerbungsprozesse durch hab
und ich find die Firma ja so toll,
wie ich sie kennengelernt, jetzt mach ich das auch für 30k.
30k weniger?
Ich weiß nicht, was die sich denken.
Seriously, die
eigentlich ist das
komplett umgedreht.
Und zwar, wenn du schon
vor der Bewerbung verarscht, also wenn du schon
bevor dem Vertrag
verarscht wirst,
ist halt die Frage, wie verarscht wirst du danach
noch? Die
haben wahrscheinlich wirklich drauf gewettet,
dass der sagt, ey, jetzt haben wir das schon gemacht,
cooler Laden, ich bleib auch. Alter, was
ein Schwachsinn. Die haben nicht wirklich die Hoffnung, dass dann jemand
ja sagt und ich bin mir da immer
noch nicht sicher, ob das jetzt Absicht
war, ob das Taktik ist
oder ob die es wirklich verplant haben.
Also es gibt ja zwei Varianten. Haben die
eine Seniorstelle mit
90 bis 105k ausgeschrieben
und wollten die eigentlich auch und waren
einfach verpeilt
oder ist das Taktik,
dass sie von Anfang an wussten, dass es
diese Stelle so nicht gibt. Was meint ihr?
Müsste das gar nicht im Vertrag stehen,
wenn er den nicht schon, der hat den Vertrag nicht
unterschrieben. Als es danach ging,
kam das ja raus mit, es ist leider
kein Budget mehr für eine Seniorstelle frei.
Dann hat er gleich gesagt,
dann halt nicht und tschüss.
Okay,
Taktik, einer meint Taktik, einer
meint HR schon verpeilt.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ich kann es mir nicht, also ich kann mir
weder das, also ich könnte mir das eine
oder das andere durchaus als plausibel
vorstellen.
Ich könnte, okay, Chat mag zum größten
Teil Taktik, denkt zum größten Teil Taktik.
Ich würde es denen noch nicht mal unterstellen wollen.
Ich könnte mir beides gut vorstellen.
Aber es ist halt echt schon lächerlich gewesen.
Also das ist auch so ein Punkt,
wo ich mir denke, ey, es ist demotivierend
verarscht zu werden.
How many
stages should an interview process have?
Zwei. Zwei finde ich durchaus
auch sinnvoll.
Einmal kurz kennenlernen so und
checken, ob alles passt. Es gibt ja Leute,
die sind ja beidseitig direkt unsympathisch.
Das muss ja nicht sein. Und dann noch
ein Technikinterview, wo es dann zur Sache
geht und da kann man theoretisch auch
danach, da auch gleich schon besprechen.
Eventuell drei Stages, wo dann
am Ende nochmal, aber hier sollte
eigentlich schon die Sache mit Geld geklärt werden.
Und danach sollte es nur noch ein bisschen Austausch
geben, so wenn es Fragen zum Vertrag gibt.
Also zwei Stages finde ich auch sinnvoll.
Mehr muss
eigentlich echt nicht sein.
Ich hätte auch keine Schmerzen, jetzt schon zu retiren.
Ne.
Ne, aber ernsthaft, also jetzt schon
retiren will ich nicht. Ich habe mir das auch schon öfters
überlegt. Also ich werde auf jeden Fall nicht bis
wann muss man jetzt arbeiten? 70 oder so?
67?
70 arbeiten auf gar keinen Fall.
Also habe ich glücklicherweise auch schon genug Geld
auf die Seite gelegt. Also ich habe
aktuell vor, so sagen wir mal mit
vielleicht ein bisschen über
50 zu retiren.
Und dann ist gut.
Hast du auch eine zusätzliche Rente
angespart?
Also ich bekomme ein bisschen Betriebsrente
von dem jetzigen Job
vom letzten Job.
Ich bekomme dann mit, also mit
67 dann oder so.
Ich habe meine
Stonks am Start, die hoffentlich bis dahin
alle noch ein bisschen gestiegen sind.
Ich habe das Haus hier am Start und ich habe auch noch
einiges an Kohle auf der hohen Kante.
Also und
mal gucken, wie das mit Erben aussieht.
Also ich denke, dass das durchaus
realistisch ist, mit Paaren 50 in Rente
zu gehen. Kommen dann die
Senior FPS Streams.
Und außerdem
stream ich weiter und mache
YouTube weiter und verdiene damit auch noch ein bisschen Geld.
Also easy. Du erbst noch was? Ja.
Es sieht zumindest
danach aus. Also es hört sich jetzt vielleicht gemein
an, also ich will das nicht falsch halten.
Ich hoffe, dass
die noch lange lebt,
ja, ich habe es echt nicht
eilig zu erben.
Meistens mag man die Leute ja auch,
von denen man erbt.
Konntest du deine Betriebsrente vom alten zum neuen
Arbeitgeber mitnehmen? Habe ich gar nicht
gefragt. Ich habe dort
einfach eine neue abgeschlossen.
Erbschaftsteuer freut sich, ja.
Die freuen sich jetzt schon. Aber
wir sind ja nicht total
blöd.
Ich glaube,
meine Mutter hat da schon einen Plan,
wie man das mit im Vorfeld
Man kann ja
entweder alles auf einmal vererben oder im Vorfeld
schon Sachen verschenken.
Und ich glaube, da ist was geplant
in der Richtung. Aber
ehrlich gesagt, rede ich ungern
über das Thema, weil
ich wünsche mir, dass meine Mutter noch
eine Weile lebt. Ja, ich habe keinen Bock
wirklich schnell zu erben. Dann
freut sich die Schenkungssteuer.
Ja.
Mal gucken.
Von meinem Vater werde ich nichts erben.
So viel ist sicher. Außer Schulden.
Industry Insights.
Okay, das ist jetzt eigentlich
unwichtig. Okay, das müssen
wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Salary Statistics.
Oh, da gucken wir noch kurz rein.
Durchschnitt, Top 75,
Top 10.
Also,
durchschnittlicher Verdienst
als Software Developer ist
61.000 Euro.
Moment.
Achso, 2022
und 2023 war gerade etwas
ich habe es gerade nicht gecheckt.
Also, 62.100 Euro.
Chatgear, wie sieht das bei euch so aus?
Sagen wir mal, wir erweitern
das jetzt mal. Kommt das bei euch ungefähr hin?
Lass mal so ein Durchschnitts
Haushalt kriegen.
Kommt das bei euch ungefähr hin?
Man muss keine
Schulden erben. Ja, ich weiß.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich werde das nicht annehmen.
Also, ich denke im Durchschnitt. Also, jetzt natürlich nur mal für Leute,
die in der IT arbeiten.
Sonst gibt es ja hier kein
rundes Bild.
Okay, ich meine, hier geht es ja auch nur um Software Entwickler.
Ich denke mal, Software Entwickler ist
im Durchschnitt eh schon ein bisschen höher, als wenn
man es jetzt über alle Leute in der IT
macht. Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass irgendwie First Level Support, es gehört ja auch irgendwie
zu IT dazu, halt nicht so viel hat im Durchschnitt.
Also, kommt ungefähr hin, denke ich.
So.
Based on Experience Level. Also,
als Junior bekommen... Chat,
wir sind gar nicht so übel mit unserer
Einschätzung, oder? Habe ich nicht mal
gesagt, als Einstiegsgehalt
Junior, wir haben doch mal,
wir haben doch mal hier hochgerechnet,
genau, guck mal. Wir haben doch mal
hier hochgerechnet, dass mein
Einstiegsgehalt heute ungefähr
46.000 Euro wäre.
So irgendwie, ne, ja,
irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Also, es kommt
doch ganz gut hin. Und das ist ja auch
nicht Frankfurt, das ist ja auch über ganz Deutschland.
Ne, Projektleiter, Gustl,
hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf. Projektleiter ist übelst der
Abfuck. Dann sagt
die Firma aber, gute
Unternehmen haben mehrere Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Sowohl für Management
mit Personalverantwortung, als auch in
Richtung Projektmanagement, als auch in Richtung
fachliche Weiterentwicklung. Wenn es
bei euch nicht gibt, dann sind
die kacke. Dann
handhabe es doch, wie die jetzt
subreddits, äh, slash r
Arbeitsleben empfehlen würde.
Neuer Job suchen und einen Chef auf den Tisch
kacken.
Das ist da immer der Default-Rat.
Man sollte sich nicht so sehr an Reddit orientieren,
ne, nur mal so angemerkt.
Okay, dann passt das hier doch.
Okay, und ein Senior, äh,
das erscheint mir tatsächlich ein bisschen,
okay, aber das ist über ganz Deutschland, über ganz
Deutschland zusammen. Okay,
was, wer verdient am meisten?
Java,
Mobile, .NET verdient am wenigsten.
Oh, Zetkin.
Im Prinzip nimmt sich alles nicht so viel.
C++,
Cagweight, SAP,
ja, das ist schon mal klar, ne?
Der Mist, der Mist,
der bringt wieder richtig Kohle, SAP.
ABAP, aber gut,
ABAP muss da auch Schmerzensgeld für bezahlen.
Was, Pearl?
Steht da wirklich Pearl irgendwo drin?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Security
verdient auch gut. Ja gut, Security,
Zeug, da muss der auch
je nachdem, was sie da haben wollen und, äh,
darunter verstehen, bei der Umfrage
muss der da auch das passende Skillset
dafür haben und da gibt's nicht so viele.
Highest and Lowest, okay, Security wird
am meisten bezahlt, Data,
Science, Zeug als nächstes,
gefolgt von SAP,
gefolgt von Go, okay,
tatsächlich, ja. Am wenigsten
wird UI Design bezahlt, gut.
Medien, Medien und Grafikgestalter
gibt's gefühlt hier auch wie Sand am Meer.
Wie sieht's in Frankfurt aus?
Alter, Frankfurt, Frankfurt, aber okay,
am meisten, am meisten gibt es
tatsächlich in
Karlsruhe, München, Mann, ich hätte eigentlich
gedacht, Frankfurt ist, Frankfurt ist weiter oben,
aber ist es gar nicht.
Frankfurt, Frankfurt ist bei 80k
und, na, aber,
ich mein, Dresden, Alter, guck mal, was
ein Unterschied. Guckt, guckt euch mal an, wie krass
der Unterschied ist. Also,
das sind, das sind, das ist jetzt ja wirklich nur
der Durchschnitt, guck mal.
Ähm, da sind einfach mal 10.000 Euro
mehr von Dresden nach
Frankfurt und von Frankfurt zu
München sind es einfach 15.000 Euro,
äh, äh, ne, 5.000 Euro mehr.
Also, inzwischen München und Dresden liegen einfach 15.000 Euro.
Man muss aber auch sagen, gerade in München
sind halt auch Wohnungen und sowas alles mega teuer.
Wo ist eigentlich Berlin? Ah, Berlin
ist auch recht hoch. Berlin ist auch so eine
Stadt, ey, da hätte ich überhaupt gar
keinen Bock drauf. Alter,
also, wisst ihr,
was mein, ich weiß, Recycle Story, wisst ihr, was mein, ich weiß, Recycle Story,
wisst ihr, was meine erste Erfahrung in Berlin war?
Ich komm Berlin am Hauptbahnhof raus und irgendein
Penner hustet mich an. Und ich dachte, mir ist
ja wieder heim.
Kein Unterschied zum Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Aber, wenn man dann rausgeht,
wenn man dann rausgeht, muss man sagen,
es ist am Berliner Hauptbahnhof auf der
einen Ausgangsseite tatsächlich
deutlich schöner als am
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof. Also, Berlin
Hauptbahnhof hat ja mehrere Ausgänge, das eine
geht irgendwie so da, das sind irgendwie
Straßen und Brücke und so.
Ich frag mich echt nicht, das krieg ich so aus dem Kopf,
ne? Und die andere Seite geht's dann so raus
Richtung Parks und so. Und wenn man da
weiterläuft, kommt man dann irgendwann auch zum Brandenburger
Tor und sowas. Also,
die, es ist, es ist doch
ein bisschen schöner am Berliner Hauptbahnhof als
am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof. Aber
meine erste Erfahrung am Berliner Hauptbahnhof
war exakt wie in Frankfurt.
Machst die Tür auf, Penner hustet mich an.
Direkt so ins Gesicht, da steht er halt einfach vor
der Tür. Habt ihr nicht gesehen?
Ja, das ist...
Okay, jetzt kommen die Schweizer. Die Schweizer
interessieren uns nicht, die verdienen jetzt zu viel.
In Zürich.
In Zug. Wo ist Zug?
Da kommt mir noch die Idee
für ein neues Wallpaper. Hau rein!
Mehr, wir brauchen mehr
White Paper Happy
Champs. Okay, nice.
Schöne Statistik, gefällt mir gut.
Wer auch immer das gepostet hat vorhin,
nice, nice find.
Was, Pearl?
Glaub ich nicht, ne?
Ne, dead.
Achso, hat nicht richtig,
hat nicht richtig Kobi pasted.
Pearl!
Pearl Developer.
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich
der eine, der das schon seit 40 Jahren macht,
der das beantwortet hat,
hier die Frage.
Frankfurt ist nicht schlecht. Ohne Scheiß,
ich wohne ja auch nicht direkt in Frankfurt.
Frankfurt und drum herum ist super.
Das einzige, was in Frankfurt
kacke ist, ist das Bahnhofsviertel und da
eigentlich auch wirklich nur die Ecke am Hauptbahnhof.
Der Rest ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also, Frankfurt echt ungleich
Bahnhofsviertel.
Das ist ja auch sowas, was auf Reddit
immer im Frankfurter Subreddit gefragt wird.
Da gibt's gefühlt, also wenn ihr Reddit,
Reddit Frankfurt,
gefühlt
ist dort jede zweite Frage,
ist es safe am Hauptbahnhof?
Warum ist eigentlich das neue
Reddit so kacke?
Gab's da nicht mal die Sache,
dass man das noch kleiner machen konnte?
Mein Gott, Alter, Reddit, Reddit,
die Seite wird immer beschissener, Alter.
Ja.
Ist es safe am
Hauptbahnhof? Das ist also gefühlt
kommt das jeden Tag dreimal die Frage.
Aber ja, es ist
safe am Hauptbahnhof.
Wir sind hier nicht irgendwo in Mexiko,
in irgendeinem Ghetto oder so oder in Brasilien.
Wir sind am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof hast du jede Menge
Penner, Drogenabhängige,
Dealer und alles mögliche.
Du hast aber auch viel Bahnsecurity und Polizei.
Also, wenn du dich nicht
gerade mit Leuten anlegen willst,
dann ist Hauptbahnhof
safe.
Es ist halt schon super assi
die Gegend, aber es ist nicht so,
dass man instant ein Messer irgendwie im Bauch
stecken hätte.
Ich gehe auf New Reddit. Moment, ist das...
Moment, Moment. Ich würde
auf Old Reddit gehen, aber es gibt auch
New Reddit? Nee.
Blödsinn. Old Reddit gibt's.
Old Reddit.
Das ist gut, ne? Old Reddit.
Bahn heute mit minimaler
Verzögerung.
Das ist die U-Bahn, die ist meistens auch pünktlich.
Ja, das ist
richtig krass in Frankfurt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, heute machen wir was anderes.
Das ist richtig krass in Frankfurt.
Ich glaube, es gibt...
Ich habe das ja schon öfters gesagt.
Ich glaube, es gibt in Deutschland
keine andere Ecke, wo
krasser Reichtum
und Armut
wie ich verrecke in den nächsten fünf Minuten
so eng zusammenliegen
wie am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Im Hauptbahnhof hast du irgendwie
den Drogenabhängigen, der
in der Ecke
liegt und gleich den Löffel
abgibt versus irgendwie
den super High IQ...
Nein, der unbedeutende High IQ ist...
Super
Mega CEO
Dude, der irgendwie
40 Millionen auf dem Konto hat.
Die laufen dann nebeneinander
quasi. Ich glaube, das
hast du zwar überall, wo es so
so gestaucht ist
alles an verschiedensten
Gruppen, aber Frankfurt
Hauptbahnhof ist glaube ich das krasseste, was wir in Deutschland
haben. Da ist wirklich...
Da ist wirklich
extreme Armut
und ja nicht nur
Armut, auch körperlich
am Ende und super
Reichtum ganz nah beieinander.
Ja, in einer Zeit ist
auch kacke. Was mir in Frankfurt immer auf den
Keks geht, sind die ganzen Umfragen Dudes.
Ja, die nerven mich auch. Richtung
Südbahnhof
standen früher immer total viele
Umfrageleute, die dann
die dann, das waren meistens wahrscheinlich
sogar irgendwelche Studenten oder so, die Geld verdienen
wollten, aber das ging mir immer auf den Sack.
Und, also
was auch Richtung
Südbahnhof am Start war,
da waren so Jesus liebt
euch Leute öfters mal früher.
Ich bin letzte Weile nicht mehr mittags zum
Südbahnhof gelaufen. Auf dem Weg zum Südbahnhof
waren immer so Jesus liebt euch
Typen unterwegs.
Und ich hatte da wirklich
teilweise an einem Tag krasses
Religionsprogramm in Frankfurt.
Ich hatte mal an einem Tag morgens
einen, der hat, da habe ich sogar
ein Foto glaube ich gemacht auf Twitter.
Hatte ich mal irgendeinen Typen, der hat gebetet
im Zug.
Also richtig arabisch und sonst
wie so gebetet.
Und dann
hatte ich auf dem Rückweg die Jesus liebt
euch Leute. Also ich hatte sie alle.
Und mir sind sie alle einfach nur offensiv.
Sack gegangen, alter.
Ich will keinen haben, der laut betet im Zug.
Ich will keinen haben, der mir erzählt, dass Jesus
mir irgendwie sonst was. Die sollen mich mit ihrem
ganzen Scheiß einfach echt in Ruhe lassen.
Das fuckt mich so ab.
Ganzes Religionskram
überall. Egal was es ist, man.
Sie sollen alle glauben, was sie wollen.
Sollen mir damit aber nicht auf den Sack gehen.
Ja, mit so Zeug
Ganz schön blöd, oder?
Die Bahn ist so spät,
ich muss mal anfangen zu beten.
Ich hatte mal einen im Zug.
Ne, das ist das, was ich fotografiert habe auf
was ich fotografiert habe auf
auf
Twitter. Auf X. Sorry, auf X.
Ich hatte mal einen im Zug.
Der hat sich die Schuhe ausgezogen
und die Füße
auf den Stuhl gestellt und dann
gebetet. Und das, alter,
das hat auch übelst gestunken, man.
Ich hab's erst gar nicht gesehen.
Ich hab gedacht,
Alter, was riecht hier denn so komisch?
Und dann guck ich
nach rechts und da sitzt halt so
ein Typ auf dem anderen Vierersitz
mit ausgezogenen Schuhen
und den
Füßen auf dem Sitz.
Das hab ich, glaub ich, irgendwie...
Findet man das irgendwo noch?
Media?
Das ist Jahre her.
Das findet man wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr, oder? Max FPS
Twitter Füße Bahn
Alter, der Dude neben mir,
der betet oder sowas, ja.
Was?
Alter!
Dafuck!
Frankfurt! Frankfurt!
Das, Leute, das ist schon eklig, man,
zugucken, man. Normalster Frankfurter
halt, ne?
Ja, oh, ich hab meine Hand liegt, genau, hier oben.
So abartig, man.
Ne, das ist...
Das ist vorbei.
Das ist vorbei bei dem, man.
Der muss nicht mitdrehen, dass er immer
in die richtige Richtung ausgerichtet ist.
Genau.
Der muss eigentlich auf...
Der müsste quasi auf so einer Art Kompass
sitzen, der sich mitdreht.
Weil, es ist ja klar, wenn er nicht in die richtige
Richtung betet, hört ihn Gott nicht.
Der braucht so eine Art Drehteller,
genau, die immer, die immer
in die richtige Richtung automatisch
sich ausrichtet. Und wenn der Zug dann fährt,
dann dreht sich das mit. Bring die Leute mal
nicht auf die Ideen, sonst kommen die noch mit sowas an.
Und, wenn wir schon grad dabei sind,
wenn wir schon grad dabei sind, könnte
da eigentlich der Teppich schon integriert sein,
oder? Weil ich glaub eh, dass
dass das, äh,
quasi die, der absolut,
der Highskill-Move ist,
wenn man mit Teppich betet. Ich glaube,
dann hört ein Gott noch besser.
Das sind genau die Leute, die in der Kirche,
hab ich früher auch nie verstanden hier,
katholische Kirche. Ich hab ja tatsächlich
noch, äh, äh, Kommunion
gemacht. Ich fand's damals schon...
Wisst ihr, was der einzige Grund war, warum
ich damals Kommunion gemacht hab?
Der einzige Grund war,
Geld.
Genau. Weil's, weil's, weil's Kohle gegeben hat.
Und, was ich damals auch schon
nicht verstanden hat, du hatt's Leute in der Kirche
sitzen, die haben normal gebetet,
die haben den, den normalen Pray-Gestelz gemacht,
und du hattest welche, die haben in der Kirche
gekniet
auf so komischen Holzdingern,
was super unangenehm aussah,
und da hab ich mir auch gedacht,
warum, warum knien die da und beten?
Ist das das Gott, die irgendwie
besser hört? Alter, ich
diese, diese... Ich denke mir, ey,
es soll jeder machen, was er will, wenn ihm
das was gibt. Nachvollziehen
können muss ich's aber nicht.
Genau. Nur wegen Kohle hab ich
das gemacht. Die sollen alle
machen, was sie wollen. Solange, solange sie mich nicht
belästigen damit, ist, ist okay.
Ja, äh, das find ich auch total eklig,
ja. Also, wo ich, wo ich,
wo ich Kommunion gemacht hab, da
hat uns der Pfarrer erzählt, wir müssen so ne komische,
komische Schale formen
mit den Händen, da kriegt man dann diese,
diesen Keks reingelegt und
sowas. Übelst weird.
Übelst weird. No comment.
Es sind quasi
Oplaten im Endeffekt, ja.
So, wir können noch ein bisschen YouTube...
Leute, ich glaube, so lang
hab ich noch nie random
geschwätzt. Zwei Stunden,
22 und 22 Sekunden
bin ich jetzt on. So lang hab ich noch nie random
Krams geschwätzt, Sonntagmorgens, ohne
dass wir mal ein YouTube-Video geguckt haben. Ich merk
schon im Hals, alter, Leute. Ich hab jetzt
zweieinhalb Stunden durchgängig geredet,
ähm,
ey, wir müssen uns, wir müssen uns jetzt mal
kurz was angucken auf, auf YouTube.
Ja, und, und dann muss ich,
und dann muss ich Nudeln mit Lachs futtern.
Was hat er mir? Zehn Technik-
Trends im Jahr 2024.
Ja, nice. Oh, Matrix.
Reference.
Ähm, da, so, hier, zack,
bumm. Fireship weiß
Bescheid. Ich bin mal gespannt, was Fireship als
Trends für das Jahr
klassifiziert.
Hast du geschaut, wie Fireship Gemini
flammt? Nee, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
was Gemini ist. Ich hab das nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
War das nicht diese Google-AI-Demo,
wo gefaked wurde bis zum Gehtnichtmehr?
Ja, genau, okay, dann,
dann hab ich's auch mitgekriegt.
Fakige.
Congratulations, you survived yet another year in the
simulation. If you still have a job in tech,
it means you survived massive layoffs.
Congratulations, you survived yet another year in the
simulation. If you still have a job in tech,
it means you survived massive layoffs,
you wouldn't get drafted into a war and outsmarted
the artificial intelligence that your boss wants
to replace you with. 2023 was the craziest
year ever, but if the rate things are accelerating,
it'll look like nothing compared to 2024.
I care deeply about the future, because
I'm going to spend the rest of my life there.
Ach, Chet, ich wollte noch die Story
vorhin zu einem Happy End bringen.
Ganz vergessen.
Nochmal anknüpfen an die Story, wo ich euch
erzählt hab. Ex-Kollege
von mir, den sie so verarscht haben bei der
Bewerbung, ihr erinnert euch, hab ich vor
einer halben Stunde oder so erzählt.
Happy End zu dieser ganzen Story,
der arbeitet jetzt bei mir.
Der hat auch eine Stelle
gekriegt, da wo ich
jetzt arbeite.
Und da wurde er nicht verarscht.
Das lief richtig gut, ich hab seine
Bewerbungsunterlagen zu meinem
Bewerbungsgespräch mitgenommen und
nachdem mein Bewerbungsgespräch gut gelaufen
ist, hab ich sie am Ende gefragt, sag mal
ich hab gesehen im Internet, ihr sucht noch
jemand, ihr sucht noch so eine Position,
ich kenn da jemand, hab
ihnen die Bewerbungsunterlagen in die Hand gedrückt und
einen Tag später haben sie sich bei ihm
gemeldet und jetzt arbeitet er auch da.
Wir haben beide am 1. April angefangen.
Also manchmal ist gut,
Leute, selbst wenn Sachen scheiße
laufen, manchmal,
manchmal ist es gut,
dass es scheiße läuft, weil sich
dadurch andere Möglichkeiten ergeben, die
sich gar nicht
angeboten hätten, hätte das vorher
geklappt. Also es ist
alles, manchmal, ich will nicht sagen
alles für alles was gut, weil es gibt
schon echt Scheiße, die man
nicht braucht, aber es ist
vieles, was auf den ersten Blick
nicht so toll aussieht, ist
bisschen Retrospektiven
mäßig betrachtet, muss gar nicht
schlecht gewesen sein.
Hast du Provisionen kassiert? Ja, hab ich
tatsächlich, die haben das hinbekommen, aber
nicht viel. Es gibt dort, wo ich
arbeite, nicht super viel Provision.
Ja.
Hab ich, hab ich.
Und die haben es tatsächlich hinbekommen,
mir das gut
zu schreiben, obwohl ich dort selbst
noch nicht angefangen habe zu arbeiten.
Ist echt so, ist wirklich so.
So im Nachhinein
betrachtet, war es
gut, ich bringe jetzt mal, ich bringe
mal kurz, ich weiß, wir wollten ein Video gucken,
aber ich bringe mal so ein Beispiel
aus, aus, aus meiner Vergangenheit,
wo ich, was ich damals, was ich damals richtig
scheiße fand. Und zwar, also
gibt's viele Momente, aber zum Beispiel,
ihr habt vielleicht das Video gesehen,
wo ich mich drüber aufgeregt hab,
dass es,
wie kacke das in meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb war.
So.
Wo ich dann auch, wo ich dann auch gekündigt hab, wo ich
weg bin, so mit diesem komischen
damals Teambuilding-Workshop,
wo es drum ging, die Leute fertig zu machen
und sowas. Hab ich euch gezeigt
und damals hätte ich mir
echt gewünscht, nicht in dieser Kack-Situation
gewesen zu sein.
Aber im Nachhinein betrachtet,
dadurch, dass ich in dieser Kack-
Situation gewesen bin, hab
ich meinen nächsten Job easy gefunden,
weil, es war ja, es war ja damals
so, in meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb,
also der, der bisschen kleinere
Internet-Provider, was nicht die
Telekom war, auch wenn manche Leute immer noch denken,
ich hab bei der Telekom die Ausbildung gemacht. Nein, hab ich nicht.
Der hat ja als Dienstleister in Frankfurt
für eine Bank fungiert
und bei der hab ich danach angefangen. Da bin ich
quasi seamless gewechselt,
weil ich gesagt hab, Alter, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Laden,
sucht ihr nicht auch was? Beziehungsweise die gesagt
haben, wollt ihr nicht? Und da
bin ich dann halt direkt, direkt rüber. Easy.
Den Job hätte ich gar nicht gekriegt.
So ohne weiteres
hätte ich nicht, wäre ich nicht in dieser
Kack-Situation gewesen
und nächste Situation war, wo es
mir so gar nicht gefallen hat mehr,
beim letzten Arbeitgeber,
ähm, wäre ich
da nicht gelandet und hätte ich nicht quasi
die Leute kennengelernt, die ich kennengelernt
habe und das gelernt, was ich gelernt
hab, hätte ich den Job nicht bekommen, den ich jetzt hab.
Also das ist für alles was gut, hätte das damals
ursprünglich beim Provider nicht geklappt,
ich hätte was anderes gemacht, wäre mein
Weg vielleicht komplett anders verlaufen
und vielleicht besser,
vielleicht schlechter, man weiß es nicht,
aber zumindest war das auch
irgendwo für was gut, so.
Ja, es ist, es ist nicht, es ist
nicht so einfach sich da aufzuraffen,
ja, also das habe ich ja auch gemerkt beim
letzten Job, ich hatte ja schon lange keinen Bock
mehr drauf, aber es war
einfach noch nicht dieser Punkt überschritten,
wo ich gesagt hätte, Alter, mir geht's zwar
auf den Sack, aber so auf den Sack,
dass ich was neues suche
und
als ich dann angefangen hab,
mich auch mal ein bisschen mehr zu informieren,
dann ging's ja wirklich Schlag auf Schlag,
ja, da haben sich gleich, haben sich ja diesmal
die Leute bei mir gemeldet, so Max, ich hab gehört
und dann
ging das ganz schnell.
Richtig gut, ja. Und das heißt,
es musste wirklich erstmal Scheiße laufen,
damit es jetzt gut lief, damit es jetzt gut läuft.
Klingt blöd, ist aber
oft so.
So, jetzt gehen wir aber,
jetzt gucken wir uns aber tatsächlich
mal das falsche Video an.
Okay.
Ja, das war ja hauptsächlich in den USA.
Und ein bisschen, und ein bisschen hier.
Hier gab's gar nicht so viele krasse Tech-Layoffs.
Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
Rates, but we've also got some wars going on.
Now, I don't stand with Palestine, I don't stand
with Israel, I don't stand with Ukraine, I don't
stand with Russia, I stand with Lockheed Martin
and Boeing, and the military industry.
Hell yeah!
Kokoda,
auf geht's!
Bob wird immer gebrochen.
...complex. These companies make the
tools we need to blow each other up, and when
you stand with that team, you really can't lose.
What you have to realize is that you're living paycheck
to paycheck, your employer is living bailout
to bailout, and the United States government is
living from war to war. If we don't get a big war
soon, the entire system could collapse, and
that's not going to bode well for tech jobs in the future.
But speaking of money, crypto is
back. Bitcoin was 16k at the beginning
of the year, and just broke 40k a couple days
ago, and crypto-bros are already predicting
that one token will be worth over a million dollars
by the end of 2020. Ja, zum Thema
crypto-bros muss man sagen, die sind ja teilweise
schon jetzt im Knast gelandet.
The price to watch for is 69k.
If it reaches this price point, the world will be flooded
with memes that will elevate FOMO to
biblical levels. In other words, the crypto-bros
Wisst ihr, was das Blöde ist? Das ist gar nicht
so unwahrscheinlich,
dass das zumindest zum Teil passiert.
Crypto-Winter might be over, bringing us a
fresh new round of Ponzi-Schemes to invest our parents'
money in. Ah, ganz
klar! Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Weil ich so selten anbringen kann.
Nicht zu vergessen, nicht zu vergessen,
Carlos Matos
from New York City,
New York.
...technology that could
come back in 2024 is
augmented and virtual reality, thanks primarily
to the Apple Vision Pro, which is
set to release in early 2024.
Apple has done some revolutionary things in the past,
like a mouse that charges from the bottom,
and if these VR goggles take off, it could lead
to a whole new round of opportunity for app
developers. However, I think that's unlikely.
Plenty of Apple cult members will drink this Kool-Aid,
but I don't think the general public is going to
fork over $3,500 to become
even more disconnected from reality.
Ultimately, though, I think this will end up being a niche product.
Das glaube ich auch nicht. Wobei ich da
tatsächlich nicht so genau das
weiß. Mir fällt mir schwer, das einzuschätzen.
Wenn die einen richtig coolen
Anwendungszweck finden,
weil, sag mal so, jetzt ist das ja eindeutig eher noch
was für Entwickler. Wenn die einen richtig
coolen Anwendungszweck finden,
ich meine, es ist immerhin
Apple, da rennen die Leute die Bude ein
für alles Mögliche. Das
könnte durchaus noch
ein bisschen
mehr Mainstream werden,
aber auf der anderen Seite so richtig,
so richtig,
ja, wie soll ich sagen, so richtig
ähm,
glauben kann ich aber auch nicht,
weil es gab jetzt so oft schon VR
und AR, was am Start war und immer
ist das wieder abgeflacht, zum größten Teil
deswegen, weil, ich meine, die Brillen sind die
letzten Jahre schon ganz klar, deutlich,
viel, viel, viel, viel besser geworden, von Auflösung,
von Tragekomfort, von Akkulaufzeit, von
allem möglichen. Also richtig da
ist es immer noch nicht. Und
das Problem an VR ist auch so ein bisschen,
es erfüllt eigentlich keinen richtigen
Anwendungszweck aktuell.
Also, manch einer wird jetzt
sagen, VR-Porn gucken, okay,
das ist aber auch der einzige Bereich, wo
meines Wissens nach VR sich wirklich
durchgesetzt hat. Und
ansonsten, so hält sich echt den
Grenzen, ja.
Cool to some people, but not appealing to the average
NPC. Now, speaking of hardware, Microsoft
just announced a few weeks ago, that it's
going to start producing its own chips, like the
Maya chip for artificial intelligence
and the Cobalt CPU, which is an ARM-based
processor, designed for general purpose
use in the cloud. VR ist bald Monitor
Ersatz für Büro, aber glaube ich nicht.
WS is also building its own ARM-based
chips, which are cheaper and more efficient than
traditional x86 chips. Now, as
of today, virtually all PCs and laptops
running Windows run CPUs based
on the x86 architecture. Da bin ich mal gespannt.
But that may not be the case in the future, because
Weil bisher konnte Intel ja eigentlich machen, was es
wollte. Intel lief immer.
Project Volterra, it's now possible to run
Windows on ARM chips. Hell, even
Intel is going to start manufacturing ARM chips.
The single most important thing anyone does
with a CPU, though, is play video games.
And just yesterday we got our first look at
the GTA 6 trailer. This will likely
be the most hyped-up video game in the history of the
world, and it's built using Rockstar's own
proprietary Rage game engine. And that
means you can't use it. What you can use is
Unity. However, Unity made a massive
blunder in 2023 by rolling out new
pricing that would charge developers every time
a game is downloaded. Unity developers
revolted, and it got so bad that they had to
roll back the pricing and apologize.
That's right, apologize. Meanwhile,
Unreal Engine released version 5.3
with some crazy new features, like a
procedural content generation framework
and its substrate material system that gets
almost indistinguishable from reality.
Now, Unreal Engine's parent company, Epic Games,
sued Apple a few years ago, saying it's a monopoly
because it takes a 30% cut on the
off-screen and doesn't allow alternative payment
methods, but it lost that suit, and that was
held up on appeal in 2023. Epic Games
is not giving up, though, with a similar ongoing
lawsuit against Google. It seems like a long
shot, but if they somehow win, it would be huge
for indie developers, because they could avoid that
30% cut to the big guy by using their
own payment processor. But now let's talk
about web development. JavaScript land is as
crazy as ever, but I think in 2024,
people will stop building new JavaScript frameworks
because nowadays they all have a similar
developer experience with signal-based
reactivity, and the race will shift to
who can build the best tools for existing
frameworks. We're seeing more visual editors
and IDEs for frameworks like React,
where you can drag and drop components instead of
coding them manually. Then you have frameworks like
Nuxt, which are like React,
where you can drag and drop components
instead of coding them manually.
Then you have frameworks like Nuxt, which have
built-in dev tools to make life easier, but
pretty soon, we should have AI writing most
of our code. There are tools like Visual Copilot,
where you can take a design in Figma,
and it will automatically write the framework code
along with Tailwind styles. In the near
future, I think every JavaScript framework
will have its own specialized tooling, along with
its own specially tuned AI, for writing
useful, accurate code. Whichever framework
does this the best will win the web development war
for the next 10 years. And I think there will be a lot of
opportunity on the web, in part because of
trends in mobile development. This trend has been
ongoing for many years, but people just don't
want to download mobile apps anymore. It's not
like 10 years ago, when you could develop an app
in your mom's basement, have it go viral, and
become a millionaire overnight. There are billions
of people using smartphones every day, but getting
their attention away from established apps is
harder than ever. Like, as you can see here...
Leute, was ist
Schein?
Ich versuche gerade... Also,
okay, CapCut, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was es ist, auch wenn es 10 Millionen verwenden.
Google Maps kenne ich, TikTok, ChatGPT,
YouTube, Google, Dings, Temu...
Leute, seriously, warum Temu,
Mann? Das ist...
Das ist...
AliExpress auf Wish bestellt,
Mann, Temu. Was Schein ist
Temu für Mode?
Temu ist AliExpress auf
Wish bestellt. Okay,
WhatsApp, Gmail kenne ich,
Instagram, Facebook, TikTok, WhatsApp, Snapchat,
Telegram, WhatsApp Business,
CapCut, keine Ahnung, Schein,
Spotify,
interessanter Snapchat,
Snapchat da immer noch so voll dabei ist.
Smartphones every day.
Ja gut, irgendwo müssen die Leute ihre Dickpics posten.
But getting their attention away from established
apps is harder than ever. Like, as you can see
here, most of my screen time goes to
Twitter and Discord. When it comes to building mobile
apps, not too much has changed, but if you're building
cross-platform, we're starting to see more low-code
tools that can build for both iOS and
Android with a drag-and-drop interface.
But now let's talk about low-level systems languages.
Rust is still growing incredibly fast
and you can now find Rust...
Leute,
blazingly fast,
Krusttiere am Start.
There was some drama with the Rust Foundation
earlier this year, and I might get sued for using
this logo, but there are some other up-and-coming
low-level languages as well, like
ZIG, the language behind the JavaScript
ZIG haben wir auch schon ausprobiert.
Was mir in ZIG tatsächlich im Kopf
hängen geblieben ist, ist diese super
weirde Pointer-Syntax.
Du kannst ja, du kannst in ZIG, musst du sowas
hier irgendwie machen.
Also, ich glaube, das hier, wenn ich's richtig
im Kopf habe,
wenn ich's jetzt richtig im Kopf habe,
das hier ist das ZIG-Äquivalent
zu dem hier in
C++.
Ganz, ganz... Ne, Moment, es war
Punkt, Sternchen, Punkt, oder?
Oder war es Punkt, Sternchen, Punkt?
Ja, ganz, ganz weird.
Ja, das
verwende ich erst, wenn es
Open Source ist.
Also, handle low-level memory management,
making it both approachable and extremely performant.
An ideal option for AI and machine
learning. And finally, that brings us to number
10, the elephant in the room.
Artificial Intelligence. Chat-GPT
has only been around for a year, although it feels
like a lot longer. And most normies out there
haven't even touched it yet. But that's going to change
over the next few years, because we now have BARD
built into Google to cannibalize its own search engine.
Mojo ist richtig pepega. Warum hast du schon
größere Sachen verwendet oder was ausprobiert?
You have Copilot built into Microsoft Office
to write all your papers and do all your spreadsheets.
An estimated 75% of all
stock trading now happens via algorithms.
And AI is being weaponized to both
launch and defend against cyber attacks.
And even our military industrial
complex friends like Palantir are using
AI to help blow people up in a more
environmentally friendly and equitable way.
But things got really crazy with generative
image AI. Ten years ago, Ian Goodfellow
published a paper proposing the first
generative adversarial network. Seven
years later, OpenAI brought us to fusion
models with DALL-E, but they still sucked pretty
hard. But then, just two years from that point,
we get images good enough to make $10,000 a
month on OnlyFans. In 2024,
a big trend to watch was text-to-video.
Stable diffusion just... AI-Influencer
...released a text-to-video
model. And at the current rate of progress,
I predict that by the end of 2024,
you'll be able to generate a full-length
Bollywood-quality movie from your laptop.
But none of this will matter if somebody
first achieves artificial general intelligence.
An AI that can actually think for itself
and not just regurgitate and remix things
humans have already done. Some people even think
this has already been achieved by OpenAI
with the leak of Q-Star. However, there's
a French guy that thinks AGI is decades
away, and some think it will never be achieved.
When that day comes, it could be a great day
for humanity. We'll never have to work or to do anything.
We'll never think again, and there'll be nothing left to do
but indulge in pleasure. On the other hand, though,
you may live to see AI-made horrors
beyond your comprehension. It could end up being
like when Faust made a deal with the devil
for unlimited knowledge and pleasure. But once
that knowledge is achieved, there's a trade-off
in the form of moral and spiritual
decline. The AI will have to adjust for this
trade-off by creating billions of lab-grown
babies, which are now a real thing, then put
them into a simulation that has a disproportionate
amount of suffering in order to offset
the pleasures experienced by the AI.
In fact, you might be in the simulation,
right now. Why else would you be watching a video
gaslighting you into thinking you're in a simulation?
You'd have to be crazy to think we're not in a simulation
right now. But again, congratulations
for making it to round 2024.
Thanks for watching, and I will see you in the next one.
Usage-technisch, bei mir ist es wahrscheinlich
eher so, dass der meiste, die meiste
User, wobei, ich glaube, es ist
50-50.
Ich glaube, ich habe ungefähr 50%
Usage, 50% Firefox,
50% Chrome,
wobei sich mein 50%
Chrome ja eher, es ist ja
Chromium und nur ein bisschen Chrome.
Also wahrscheinlich, ich würde mal
sagen, ich habe 40%, okay, realistisch
betrachtet, lass mal mir denken, wie wird meine Browser
Usage aussehen? Da kommt ja auch noch
iOS Safari dabei.
Also, weil es gibt ja oft
iOS nur Safari. Also,
wahrscheinlich sind es, wahrscheinlich sind es 30%,
30%
Firefox, 30% Chrome,
30% Safari
und
10% irgendwie
random shit, wo Webseiten anzeigt.
Opera GX,
nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Kein Opera, okay.
Wisst ihr was? Wir gucken uns
keine 39 Minuten an.
Ich gucke mir die finale
Tierlist von ihm an,
ob ich der Sache zustimmen würde.
Was zum Teufel ist Waterfox?
Was ist Waterfox?
Waterfox ist yet another Firefox-Clone.
Okay, braucht keiner.
Wo ist die letzte Tierlist?
Final Tierlist?
Ja.
Okay.
Also, aus seiner Sicht ist
aus seiner Sicht
ist Based Tier ist Firefox.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das hier ist.
Excellent hier ist Brave und Chromium.
Okay, bin ich aber froh,
dass ich wenigstens
einen exzellenten Browser benutze.
Waterfox, noch nie gehört.
Was ist das da oben denn?
Weiß das irgendjemand? NordVPN?
NordVPN Browser.
Keine Ahnung.
Früher gab es noch Iceweasel.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch als Browser gibt.
Das war der Debian Firefox Fork.
Das ist LibreVolv.
Okay, alles klar.
So, dieses...
Decent ist Firefox.
Ah, nee, das ist Harden Firefox.
Firefox.
Ice Weasel Cat.
Vermutlich.
Moon irgendwas.
Moon Ding. Das ist auch irgendein Firefox Fork.
Keine Ahnung, was das hier ist.
Das ist Vivaldi.
Ja, Vivaldi ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich fand den am Anfang super spannend,
was da passiert.
Das ist ja... Also, Vivaldi ist quasi
von den Opera-Leuten.
Der nächste Browser, nachdem sie Opera
an die Chinesen verkauft haben.
Ich finde das gar nicht so übel.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich habe keinen Anwendungszweck da jetzt für mich
mit Vivaldi.
Safari fehlt. Ja, das ist auch gut.
Safari ist auch trashed hier.
Leider der einzige Browser, der unter iOS
verfügbar ist.
Das ist Edge. Nee.
Ist das hier Edge oder das ist Edge?
Das ist Edge.
Was ist das? Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
was das ist?
Chrome geht nicht unter iOS. Das ist alles Safari.
Gnome Web.
Ja gut. Das sind die mit der eigenen
Engine, die
nix anzeigen kann.
So, Spyware-Tier
ist Chrome, Edge und Opera.
Ja, Opera, China-Chinesen
Dings, Spy,
hier Microsoft Spy und hier Google Spy.
Ja, das ist alles Safari.
Korrekt. Deswegen funktioniert ja auch
fast nix unter iOS. Okay, fast nix
ist übertrieben, aber deswegen
funktioniert, ups, hä, hab ich das nicht
grad schon, deswegen funktioniert halt
auch einiges nicht. Es gibt ja
Can I Use, es gibt ja diese Webseite,
wo ihr vergleichen könnt,
was die unterschiedlichen Browser unterstützen.
Kann man hier sagen, hier
zum Beispiel Chrome und Safari.
Ja, nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie
Safari, den letzten Safari
und den letzten Chrome
und den letzten
Firefox und dann
hab ich keine Ahnung, wie man die Seite bedient.
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht
so, nicht so, ja,
da sieht man schon mal, dass
Safari ganz viel nicht kann.
Safari kann hier auch ganz viel nicht und hier
kann auch Safari ganz viel nicht.
Also, es sieht, wobei, was jetzt ein bisschen blöd
ist, in der Statistik sieht es fast so
aus,
als könnte Firefox noch
weniger, aber das Ding ist halt,
mag vielleicht ne Summe sein, aber Firefox
unterstützt eindeutig die wichtigeren
Sachen
und so, dass kaum ein Unterschied zu Chrome
ist und Safari hat halt echt,
keine Probleme. Zum Beispiel eine Sache,
Web Notifications,
can I use?
Auch so ein Ding,
was super lang von
Safari nicht unterstützt wurde
und mittlerweile, mittlerweile
haben wir das, also, Safari iOS,
guck mal, selbst Safari iOS,
ach, ich hab nicht Safari iOS
benutzt, ich hab einfach nur Safari benutzt.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss Chrome,
Firefox und nicht Safari.
sondern safari ios warum was ist was ist denn der der es ist hier so hinterlegt
ach das wahrscheinlich letzte stable version oder so haben wir jetzt wir
jetzt vergleichen safari ios da sieht schon da sieht schon deutlich düsterer
aus mittlerweile und die wollten dass die wollten das guck hier guck hier die
safari hat echt das ist halt das ding safari ist halt wirklich als safari ios
ist wirklich grausam nervig und gerade was sowas wie web notifications angeht
da hat apple keinen bock drauf es hat richtig dumm dass es nicht geht
chrome für android kann schon eine ganze weile
also safari ist was technologien angeht der neue internet explorer
es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so extrem schlimm wie damals mit internet explorer
6 und sowas aber es geht in die richtung also wenn du davon ausgeht also
ich weiß nicht warum ich das jetzt hier so ein bisschen auf die rechte Karte
gehe mal davon aus dass deine webseite wenn sie nicht funktioniert oder deine
webanwendung nicht funktioniert dass es höchstwahrscheinlich der safari sein wird
wo sie nicht richtig funktioniert safari auf mac ist auch nicht ganz so schlimm
wie safari unter ios wie man gesehen hat safari unter ios ist halt krepp leider
das einzige was es gibt ich habe übelst hunger was ist das hier das slow death of
windows
das kommt jetzt nicht highlight der game awards
highlight der game awards
juck mich null was das hier
the day before ist wohl der größte spiel- reihenfall des jahres das habe ich null
mitgekriegt ich also im vorfeld
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen ich habe beim lost mal ein bisschen reingeguckt
das war ja wohl irgendwie lange zeit listet auf steam und die haben wohl
auch ganz viele sachen angekündigt das ist best game ever wird und wobei wir wissen da
Ark is best game ever.
Und total viel versprochen,
aber es ist wohl irgendwie ein Studio,
was sonst noch nie was auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
Und jetzt kam es raus
und ist irgendwie so ein Extraction Game.
The Scam Before.
Das wäre richtig nice,
wenn das möglich ist.
Man kann ja aktuell schon
sideloaden unter iOS, aber so
restriktiv, dass es halt abfuckt.
Zum Beispiel werden
sideloaded Apps automatisch wieder runtergeworfen
alle sieben Tage.
Chat, oder? Kennt sich jemand damit aus?
Ich glaube, alle sieben Tage musst du sideloadete
Apps unter iOS neu installieren.
Das ist das richtige Abfuck.
Da lobe ich mir doch mein Nvidia
Shield TV.
Das habe ich jetzt auch schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Das gibt immer noch Updates dafür
und du kannst im Zweifelsfall,
wenn es irgendwelche Apps nicht
im Android TV App Store,
Shield TV, Android TV App Store gibt,
einfach sideloaden.
Und ich habe mir einfach zum Beispiel
einen Browser drauf gesideloadet,
den man gescheit mit Fernbedienung bedienen kann.
Jetzt hat man auch einen gescheiten Browser drauf.
Also, sinnig. Sehr sinnig.
Die Möglichkeit zu sideloaden.
Jede Woche.
Also, das ist halt das Dumme,
dass das unter iOS nicht möglich ist.
Sollte es unter iOS auch möglich sein
in Zukunft, easy Apps
zu sideloaden, das würde auch
beispielsweise ganz viele Open Source Projekte
vor nicht so große Probleme stellen.
Du kannst dir dann einfach die Sachen,
die man sideloaden und gut ist,
muss nicht über den App Store gehen
und da könntest du dann auch Sachen erlauben
als Apps, die Apple halt vielleicht
einfach nicht so gerne sieht
und dementsprechend nicht dem App Store zulassen will.
War gespannt.
War echt gespannt, was da kommt.
Heute, ich werde auf jeden Fall
heute den Kreisel-Crime machen.
Heute Mittag basteln wir, aber ich habe mir überlegt,
wisst ihr, was ich mir gerne mal angucken würde?
Steam-Themen.
Würde mir gerne mal angucken.
Docke.
Ich habe so viel Zeug auf.
Das ist ein
Docker-Management-Frontend
von dem gleichen Typ, der
Uptime-Kuma programmiert hat.
Ich habe keinen richtigen Anwendungszweck für.
Es ist auch eindeutig
eher was für den Heimbereich, also nichts
irgendwie für den Business-Enterprise-Sektor.
Aber ist immer ganz gut
auf dem aktuellen Stand zu sein.
Docke.
Bin mal gespannt.
Das ist quasi ein Docker-Compose-Web-Interface.
Gucken, ob man sowas braucht,
ob es irgendwie Sinn macht.
Es ist ein Web-Interface für Docker-Compose-Files.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Portena,
nur um hoffentlich nicht so scheiße wie Portena.
Ich weiß, viele mögen Portena.
Ich mag Portena nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe noch nie einen Telegram-Bot gebaut.
Ach nee, du suchst einen Anwendungszweck.
Das Erste, was mir einfallen würde,
ist der Vorteil von einem Telegram-Bot,
was Smart Home angeht,
ist, dass du mit dem Telegram-Bot
dein Smart Home steuern kannst,
ohne dass du VPN-Access nach zu Hause brauchst.
Also du könntest beispielsweise
einen Chatraum haben mit deinem Bot
und dann sagst du Klimaanlage an,
sagst du dem Bot
und Home Assistant schaltet die Klimaanlage an,
ohne dass du ein VPN-Access brauchst
und das Dashboard von Home Assistant.
Ja, haben gestern Leute auch schon geschrieben.
By the way,
ihr könnt Private Messages auf Twitch einfach ausschalten,
habe ich auch gemacht.
Private Messages,
auf Twitch sind nervig.
Na klar, was sonst?
Was schreiben die Bots denn so?
Ich habe noch keinen Only-Fans-Bot-Spam bekommen,
weil ich meine PNs ausgeschaltet habe.
Was schreiben die denn so?
Posten die Booba-Links?
Ey gut, was sonst?
Hast du Erfahrung mit True-Scalen?
Erfahrung ist zu viel gesagt.
Wir haben das ausprobiert im Stream.
Ich war anfänglich,
ich war anfänglich,
recht positiv angetan davon,
aber umso mehr ich mich damit beschäftigt habe im Stream,
umso weniger hat es mir gefallen.
Irgendwo im Archiv ist dann auch noch der Link,
wenn du dir das angucken willst,
aber ist nix, wo ich Bock hätte, das zu verwenden.
Aber natürlich immer die Frage,
was man sucht.
Also ich habe das im Hinblick auf,
wie eignet sich das als Komplettlösung gesehen?
Also sprich,
für Webinterface um Storage,
Shares einzurichten,
um VMs anzulegen und um Container laufen zu lassen.
Und dafür war, hat man gemerkt,
so noch nicht so rund.
Ach, so was schreiben die da, okay.
Ja, gut, gut, dass ich meine PNs ausgeschaltet habe auf Twitch.
Na, Software, welche auf Linux basiert,
wie wäre es einfach mit Debian?
Das basiert auch auf Linux, habe ich gehört.
Ich meine, es sei denn,
du willst unbedingt ein grafisches Interface zum Netzwerk Shares einrichten.
Kannst du auch Unraid verwenden.
Ich benutze aktuell Unraid,
auch wenn ich nicht richtig glücklich bin.
Ich habe lange Zeit Unraid immer belächelt,
habe ich gesagt, so eine Kack-Noob,
so eine Kack-Noob-Software,
so für den richtigen High-IQ-Senior-Linux-Dev-Biz-Win-Sec-Ops-Engineer
ist so eine Webinterface-Geklicke-Nix.
Aber mittlerweile habe ich das auch gelaut.
Ja, MediaVault habe ich auch ausprobiert,
dass...
Das ist auch so semi-nice nur.
Aber das Schöne an Open MediaVault ist,
es basiert auf Debian.
Das heißt, wenn du Debian installieren willst,
kannst du einfach Open MediaVault, glaube ich, draufklatschen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Mit Döner kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Wahrscheinlich 50 Storm Calling und 42 Schildrestwaffe oder sowas.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Weiß ich nicht.
Musste mal...
Schau doch mal in den Discord, in das Discord von Eden.
Da gibt es doch Klassen...
Klassen-Challenges.
Da findest du bestimmt noch ordentliche Specs.
Außer, man hat Eden-Skill-Vorschläge ingame.
Minimal-Debian.
Debian ist doch schon sehr minimal.
Ja, wie man den Debian-Installer durchklickt, das...
wissen wir, ne?
Okay.
Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Heute Mittag machen wir wahrscheinlich Docke.
Und wir sehen uns.
Advent of Code.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir es heute machen.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich was anderes machen.
Und jetzt gibt's...
Nudel...
mit Lachs. Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.